Малышка Hey Leute!
Die unangenehmsten Menschen der Welt. Dankeschön. Vielen, vielen Dank, meine Damen und Herren. Stefan Tietze ist im Haus! Hey, Essen, was geht? Da stehen zwei Leute, seht ihr alle nicht, die stehen, weil die richtige Fans sind, okay? Von euch ist niemand aufgestanden, da geht jemand die Treppe hoch, der hat gar nicht verstanden, was es schon losgeht, naja. Und mit dabei natürlich Florentin Will, liebe Leute. Danke, ach, hol auf, hör auf jetzt, hör auf, ernsthaft, hör auf. Ach Leute, schön, dass ihr da seid. Aber hast du das, hast du das damals gemacht, also wenn du Theater gespielt hast, warst du noch in der Rolle beim Verbeugen? Überhaupt nicht, weil manchmal ist der Bösewicht noch so ein bisschen zum Augenzwinkern und man dachte immer so, ah! Aber es ist dann auch der, der so das Schwert in der Brust steckt, also am Ende einfach noch mal so, verbeugt er so, ah! Und dann wirklich stirbt, das ist ein großes Problem gewesen. Lieben Gruß natürlich auch heute an unsere Zuschauer auf den oberen Rängen, aha, die Adeligen, ja, sehr gut. Da hält jemand eine Krücke hoch, war okay. Gut. Setzt euch bitte hin, versicherungstechnisch, ihr könnt da nicht runterfallen. Ja genau, bitte einfach hinsetzen, danke schön. Es geht nicht um euch, es geht um die Leute, auf die ihr fallen würdet. Die sind versichert, ihr seid nicht versichert, das ist so ein bisschen der Unterschied. Telegram, Telegram, Telegram ist auch am Start hier offensichtlich. Herzlich willkommen die Telegram-Telegram. Vielleicht merkwürdigste Product Placement aller Zeiten, aber gut. Aber hat irgendwie auch was gebracht, muss man auch schon sagen. Wo ist die Facebook-Faktion? Okay, gar nichts. Die Zahlen sind anscheinend eine Lüge. Niemand ist auf Facebook. Niemand mag Facebook. Willst du das heute stehen? Heute Stand-Up oder was? Ja, wir haben so eine große Bühne, wir haben so viel Platz hier hinten. das ist grossartig. Wir können überall sein, es ist fantastisch, Essen hat grosse Bühnen auf jeden Fall. Das stimmt, hier ist auch wirklich ein ganz fantastisches Gebilde heute wieder. Man ist immer so, Wien war dieses Wiener-Ding und hier ist halt dieses, wenn ich sagen müsste, das ist ein Essener Gebäude, das ist ein Essener Gebäude, mit diesen Nieten und Nägeln und Schrauben.
Das wurde auch gebaut, um noch zwei weitere Weltkriege auszuhalten. Da hat man einfach gesagt so, also so wie es momentan...
Man war hier optimistisch oder pessimistisch, je nachdem, also nee, jetzt im Sinne von...
Ja, man ist mit der Zeit geschwommen, hat gesagt einfach, komm, lass uns einfach mal gucken, wie es läuft.
Heute ist es entspannt, oder?
Heute ist es total entspannt, wir sind total ruhig.
Ah Leute, wie geht's euch?
Seid ihr gut drauf, gut hergefunden, sehr gut.
Oh, einer schüttelt den Kopf, einer schüttelt den Kopf.
Der mit der Krücke?
War es der mit der Krücke?
Ich glaube, du hast es keinen guten Tag, oder?
Bin nicht gut drauf heute.
Ich habe heute nur schlechte Nachrichten bekommen.
Mein Toast war verbrannt, ist verbrannt auf dem Boden gefallen. Oh, solche Tage gibt's, ne? Solche Tage gibt es durchaus. Es gibt Tage. Ich habe schon lange keinen Toast mehr getoastet. Ich bin mittlerweile so faul geworden, dass... Ist die Post-Toast-Phase des Floridin Wilde eigentlich? Es ist Post-Toast auf jeden Fall. Ich würde sagen, Prä-Toast war ich besser, ganz ehrlich, muss ich ganz ehrlich sein. Post-Toast, mal gucken, was noch kommt. Aber ich habe keine Geduld mehr für Toast. Ich bin einfach... Ich stecke ihn einfach so, wie er ist, in mich rein. Toast ist mir zu viel mittlerweile. Aber warum? Ist es die Dauer? Ich habe gestern ein Video geschaut, um herauszufinden, ob die Zahl zwei auf dem Toaster wirklich sagt, dass es zwei Minuten lang toastet. Nee, wobei das Video war nicht ganz eindeutig, weil der letzte Toaster war wirklich genau noch zwei Minuten fertig. Naja, es ist eines dieser Internetvideos, das Dinge widerlegt, die niemand behauptet hat. Heute mache ich ein Video, wo ich herausfinde, dass Kühlschränke nicht radioaktiv sind. Wir haben hier drei Geigerzeller. Na ja, kommt tief in deinem Innern, dann dachtest du schon, drei ist drei Minuten. Nie, nee, nee, nee. Was soll drei sonst, drei ist drei Minuten? Dachte ich nie. Was dachtest du denn? Ich dachte, das sind halt so Wärme, das ist halt so warm. Warmigkeit. Ich habe auch nie realisiert, dass die unterschiedlich lang sind. Ich dachte, die werden unterschiedlich heiß. Was ich nicht verstehe, hast du einen Eierkocher? Ist ein bisschen Special Interest heute. Nee, das ist eher was für die obere Reihe, oder? Hab ich recht, Leute? Ey, Eierkocher. Ah, ich hasse euch. Bisschen nicht, haben wir vorher nicht angekündigt, ist die grosse Eierkocher-Sendung heute. Aber man kann da einstellen, am Eierkocher kannst du den Härtegrad einstellen und dann hast du ja auch noch dieses Gebilde, wo du Wasser reinmachst, in den Eierkocher. Ja. Becher. Oh, oh, Frau Professorin in der ersten Reihe. Oh, okay, gut. Oh la la, bonjour. Hier in Essen haben wir Eierkocher studiert, alles klar, ciao.
Ah, bonjourno. Gott im Himmel, ey. Ach, ein Becher. So, und dieser Becher, ähm, dieser Becher, da kann man auch nochmal, also da muss zum einen die Eieranzahl, wird dann am Rand angezeigt, und der Härtegrad des Eis. So, jetzt verstehe ich aber nicht, wenn ich jetzt da ganz hart mache, drei Eier, sehr hart, ist sehr viel Wasser, mache ich rein so und dann aber außen vom Eierkocker mache ich dann auf die geringste Stufe. Was kommt dann raus? Ich glaube, da kannst du einen Glitch auslögen, dann wird es ausgebildet werden. Wenn ich das mache, ist ein Paralleluniversum entstanden, wie wenn man Antipasti und Pasti ist. Oder es kommt einfach nur ein, auf dem Display steht einfach nur, ich bin enttäuscht. Sorry? Ich bin einfach, ne, ich bin nicht kaputt, es geht genauso, aber ich bin einfach enttäuscht, dass du dich nicht an die Regeln hältst. Oder einfach so ein, ja was denn jetzt? Ja. Was willst du jetzt? So ein H-U-H steht dann da. Wie mein Vater mir erklärt hat, der war lange Programmierer und der hatte so ein Problem, der hat mit ganz... Bis was passiert ist? Bis zu einem grossen Meltdown. Einfach alle Kabel verschwunden sind. Der Server-Meltdown von 2003. Als er in seiner Firma eines Tages hingekommen ist und es gab keine Kabel mehr. Und dann mussten sie aufhören. Amazon muss morgen auch Schluss machen, wenn die keine Kabel mehr haben. Irgendwann will es erreicht sein. Die Daten kommen nicht mehr von A nach B. Das war's. Die kommen von A ins Weltall, wir wissen nicht, was da noch passiert, und dann ist es bei B.
Keine Ahnung, aber der hatte immer ein Problem mit einem Programm, wo immer eine Fehlermeldung kam, die HUH hieß.
Und dann hat er wirklich alles durchblättert, alle seine Informatik-Sachen durchblättert, Fehlermeldung HUH, was soll das bedeuten, bis er wirklich herausgefunden hat, dass die Fehlermeldung einfach heisst, hä? Ist es wirklich so, dass sie ohne H, U, H, Hibernating, Unlimited, Heritage, nee, einfach nur, hä, wat? Das kann auch so ein, auf Deutsch ist es W, A, T, sein so, warte mal kurz, ich check das kurz, hä? Auf Deutsch wäre es W, A, T. Wat? Einfach Wat? Da würde man auch lange suchen. Aber manchmal sind Sachen gar nicht so sophisticated wie Becher zum Beispiel. Manchmal ist es, diese krasse Verschlüsselung im Internet, diese PGP-Verschlüsselung, heisst auch nur Pretty Good Privacy. Ja. Und man denkt sich so, ja, ist es so gut? PGP. Vielleicht ist es gut, aber der Titel suggeriert nicht, dass es wirklich besser ist. PGP ist übrigens der Name, mit dem sich mal jemand mir vorgestellt hat. Der hat gesagt, ich heiße, sagen wir jetzt mal, Peter Gerhard Pedersen. Peter Gerhard Pedersen. Meine Eltern haben sich nicht ganz durchdringen können, den Gag zu machen, mich Peter Pedersen zu nennen. Deswegen haben sie Peter Gerhard Pedersen genommen, weil noch ein Stück Menschlichkeit in ihm war. Und er hat gesagt, ja, ich heiss Peter Gerhard Pedersen, aber meine Freundin nennt mich PGP. Ja, welche Freundin? Egal was passiert, ich will nicht ein Freund werden, mein Name. Ja, genau. Es funktioniert einfach nicht. Man kann sich nicht so vorstellen. Was ist denn mit FDP Will eigentlich geworden? Hat sich das durchgesetzt? Es läuft, ich bin mittlerweile im Kreisverband, Politik ist einfacher als man denkt, irgendwie, ich sitze da und die Leute kommen zu mir und haben Beschwerden, die Ampel geht nicht, die springt von rot auf gelb, aber nicht mehr von gelb auf grün und ich sag's so, so wie in der Politik und dann lachen die und lachen die und dann gehen sie nach Hause. Irgendwann darf man einfach fahren. Niemand weiß. Irgendwann darf man bei Ampeln einfach fahren.
Wirklich?
Ja.
Wenn man zu viel hat, einfach...
Ich weiß es nicht genau, Frau Professorin, die Grenze.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wann die ist. Bei fünf Minuten ist so... die ist lächerlich kurz.
Kein Führerschein. Okay.
Aha, dafür reicht es ja nicht.
Get your life straight, ma'am.
Sie hatte mit 18 die Möglichkeit...
Du kannst nicht alles wissen und keinen Führerschein haben. Ja, entweder lerne ich fahren oder ich lerne alles über Becher. Ich würde sagen, das ist nicht richtig entschieden. Das ist nicht richtig entschieden. Tatsächlich der grösste Mindblow meiner Kindheit war, ich habe jeden Tag... Fruchtiger. Auch, dazu kommen wir... Fruchtiger, Fruchtiger, Leute, am I right?
No, kein Mind geblout. Die Minds bleiben ungeblouten. Bleiben kühl heute. Ich habe damals wirklich jede Woche Pudding gegessen, also ständig Pudding. Meine Kindheit ist voller Pudding, von oben bis unten. Sieg an deinen Fotos, was in der Kindheit ist ist. Aber gut. Oh, okay. Burnt, okay. Wir kommen zum Roast von Florian. Aber das war auch der Roast von Florian. 70 Minuten lang, er ist fett. Und da hieß es dann auf dem Pudding, einmal bitte hier Pudding rein in den Becher, oh okay, da hätte ich schon ahnen können, ich wusste nicht, was das sein soll. Und dann hieß es, und dazu zwei Tassen Milch. Und ich habe immer zwei Tassen aus dem Schrank geholt, habe zwei Tassen mit Milch gefüllt und habe beide Tassen in den Bichet, spreche ich es richtig aus, Madame? Bichet. In den Bichet, sorry, excusez moi, habe ich zwei Tassen in den Bichet gekippt und dann schön mein Pudding angerührt und mir schön in mein Mundloch reingeballert, bis irgendwann mal mein weisser Bruder gesagt hat, ja, das Kunsthau mit dem Oberen-Oderen-Tosten-Macher. Noch nie habe ich so etwas Kluges gehört. Danke. Und seitdem kann ich doppelt so viel Pudding essen. Sehr gut. Steine Berg auf. Und dann kam die Pubertät. Ja, dann geht's mir gar nicht. Setzt an. Ach Gott, oh Gott. Ja. Ich habe ganz kurz eine Frage, was machen Sie da? Sie stehen, machst du Security? Was ist, weil du, ja, weil du mit dem, oder bist du Zuschauer und hast dich einfach da hingesetzt. Ich finde das fantastisch, weil du genau an der Blickachse sitzt. Ich musste die ganze Zeit anstechen, ich habe diese ganze Pudding-Sache gar nicht mitbekommen, aber du bist Security tatsächlich. Okay, gut. Es war völlig verwirrend, wir hatten noch nie Security und plötzlich sitzt jemand mit der Blickrichtung ins Publikum. Das sagt mir eigentlich geil, eigentlich geil so ein Paradigmenwechsel, man muss sich einfach aufs Publikum gucken. Seitdem uns bei der letzten Show in Wien, ich sag mal so, Bananentee überreicht wurde, haben wir beschlossen, Security anzuorganisieren, die alles, was versucht, auf die Bühne zu kommen, abzuwehren. Ja, und Taschen wurden ja auch nach Bananentee durchsucht, nicht nach Bomben, die waren okay. Wir haben extra aus Korea einen Bananentee-Scanner einfliegen lassen, die es tatsächlich gibt. Den einen Bananenteehund, der das herausfindet, der eine Hund. Seit drei Jahren arbeitslos ist und zuhause und seine Frau, nein, du bist nicht nutzlos, du bist nicht nutzlos, es kommt wieder bessere Zeit. Nein, du bräckst einen Teil bei zur Gesellschaft. Ich hätte blinden Hund werden sollen. Nein, da kommt schon, da kommt jemand auf dich zu. Du schaffst das, du schaffst das. Und dann eines Tages klingelt das Telefon an, dann, ja, ja, könnte ich machen, ja, ja, Schatz, wir ziehen nach Essen. Für eine Show. Aber freut uns, dass wir ihm eine Chance gegeben haben. Ja, nee, sehr gut, finde ich gut. Vielen Dank, dass du aufpasst, dass du alles... Aber was willst du machen? Hast du eine Waffe? Das darfst du nie... Nein das ist, nein, stopp, das ist das einzige, was du nicht machen darfst, ist hinterfragen, ob Security wirklich sinnvoll ist, weil das ist ihre grosse Schwäche. Das ist genauso, wenn jemand fragt, wie du in dem Moment, das meint er nicht so, wir sagen Dinge, das ist alles in einem Comedy-Kosmos. Ich sehe das Samurai-Schwert hinter dir stehen, das ist okay. Das ist genauso, wenn du merkst, dass eigentlich zum Beispiel dein Lehrer nicht wirklich was gegen dich machen kann. Nicht wirklich was gegen dich in Hand hat. Aber wenn er bis drei gezählt hat, dann passiert doch was. Nee, da passiert eben gar nichts. Wie, wenn Erwachsene bis drei gezählt haben, passiert nichts? What? Ich würde gar nicht sagen, ich zähle bis drei, sondern ich zähle bis acht, einfach um ein bisschen mehr Spielraum zu erlauben. Um dem mehr Zeit zu erkaufen und um auch eine bessere Idee zugekommen. Ein, sechs, sieben, warte, jetzt lass mich kurz nochmal googeln. Kann man Schüler schlafen? Acht, zehn. Was, ich weiß nicht. Ich glaube, ich weiß nicht. Glaubst du, du wärst ein guter Vater? Ach so, ich dachte, nein, ich dachte gerade, du fragst, offensichtlich nicht, ich dachte gerade, du fragst, ob ich ein guter Security-Mann wäre und die Antwort wäre die gleiche gewesen. Nein, in dem Lachen auch. Ich glaube, gut, gehen wir kurz zur Vaterfrage zurück. Ich glaube, ich wäre kein guter Vater. Ich habe auch großen Respekt davor, wenn Kinder in der U-Bahn Fragen stellen oder in öffentlichen Räumen Fragen stellen und Eltern müssen dann die Frage beantworten. Und Kinder ja auch Fragen stellen wie, wie funktioniert Licht, wie funktionieren Mikrofone und du hast so ungefähr eine Ahnung, aber du weisst es nicht wirklich, weil die letzte Netflix-Doku war über Formel 1 und du weisst nicht genau, wie das jetzt funktioniert. Du hast dir alle Formel 1 Facts aufgeschrieben, weil du dir denkst, falls du dich mal jemand fragt. Aber dein Kind stellt die falschen Fragen, dein Kind fragt, wie Licht funktioniert, und du stehst in der U-Bahn und sagst, ja, da sind so Wellen und dann guckt dich so jemand dann an von der Seite und sagt, oh Gott, noch nie von Wellenteilchen-Diolismus gehört, du Vollidiot. Ich würde meinem Kind immer was zu essen geben, einfach diese Zündung. Ja, genau. Einfach sagen, wirklich gute Frage, einfach zack Schnullerei. Gute Frage, behalt bitte deine Neugier weiter, aber hier ist eine Milchschnitte, bitteschön.
Und irgendwann weiss das Kind einfach, dass es eine Milchschnitte kriegt.
Papa, wo brauchst du eine Milchschnitte?
Aus Milch und Schnitten.
Das weiss ich jetzt aber, so, das weiss ich. Aber mehr weiss ich auch nicht.
Nee, aber was, ich hab mich einfach, was du jetzt machen, also was ich ja jetzt machen würde, wenn jetzt jemand auf die, weil, aber bist du denn so Martial Arts mässig ausgebildet oder? Blinzle einmal für ja und zweimal für nein, weil ich würde jetzt nicht wissen, was ich dann machen könnte. Ich würde mich auch gerne mal irgendwo hinstellen, aber auch so bei uns, damals in der Schulzeit waren immer, wir sind ja grosse Borussia Dortmund-Fans bei uns gewesen.
Hey, hey, ich weiß nicht, ob man jetzt den Essen grossen Massen mitreicht. Wer enthält sich? Einmal alle Enthaltungen! Yes! Enthaltung! Das ist aber ein bisschen deutscher. Neutralität! Yes! Yes, ich bin für gar nichts! Naja, und da gab es dann immer das grosse Stadion und es musste sehr viele Betreuer und Security-Leute haben. Und es waren immer die, wo man dachte, hm, du könntest gar nichts ausrichten, du könntest nichts tun. Es waren Leute wie ich, die so lang waren oder klein oder halt, wo keine Muskeln aussagen, dass ich jetzt jemanden umrahmen kann. Es ist ja tatsächlich so, in Amerika gibt es das ja, glaube ich, hat jeder Laden Security, egal was es ist, der kleinste Modeladen. Und dann waren wir in so einem Waffelladen, Waffelladen, Waffelladen und ich würde sagen, vielleicht Top drei fettesten Menschen, die ich jemals in meinem Leben gesehen habe, war Security in dem Waffelladen. Was nicht heisst, dass das seinen Job nicht gut macht, aber ich mir dachte, hat der auch so angefangen, oder?
Aber die Bedienung war sehr dünn. Die Bedienung, und wenn man in Köln durch die
Fußgängerzone geht, sind die Bedienungen von Donut-Läden. Ich will jetzt nicht, wir werden
kurz pauschal, ich will jetzt nicht zu pauschal werden, aber die Bedienungen aus Donut-Läden
sehen so ein bisschen aus wie das Nachher-Bild. Ja, das stimmt. Eines Donut-Konsumenten. Ja. So, aber bei dem Waffelladen habe ich in Erinnerung, war jemand sehr schlank. Der hat wahrscheinlich gerade erst angefangen. Gerade erst angefangen. Und dann bist du zur Security, wenn du breit genug bist. Ja, der Security sagt dann, ah, erster Tag. Okay, viel Spaß. Erster Tag. Viel Erfolg. Oder vielleicht war der auch einfach kein professionelles Security-Guard, sondern hat sich einfach persönlich beworben, hat gesagt, so Leute, kann ich hier arbeiten, egal als was? Aber Sie kriegen keine Security-Startup? Ja, Sie können sich gerne bewerben, Sie kriegen halt nur keine kostenlosen Donuts. Okay. Wollen Sie hier immer noch arbeiten? Kann ich eine lange Angel mit zur Arbeit nehmen? Ja, wenn es Ihnen bei der Ausführung Ihres Jobs hilft, Leute, die Bananentee reintragen wollen, auszusieben. Einfach, falls die Leute weglaufen, dass ich sie fangen kann mit einer Angel und dann ansonsten eigentlich alles in Ordnung. Aber ist es schon eine handelsübliche Angel? Ist es keine Donut-Angel? Das kommt darauf an, was Sie jetzt als handelsübliche Angel beschreiben würden. Im Angelsport gibt es natürlich viele verschiedene Angeln, Angels natürlich, sagt man im Fischsport, ich kenne mich aus.
Und ansonsten kann ich auch einfach die Donuts, die ihr sonst wegwerfen würdet, einfach in mich reinstecken.
Nee, aber die kommen mit dem Müll. Oh, der wurde ganz kurz ein bisschen so zahlkritisch.
Oh!
Kurz ist, dass wir nicht nur Gags machen, sondern auch kurz sagen, wir sind in der Überflussgesellschaft. Es werden zu viele Donuts weggeworfen, das ist dein Problem? Das ist das Problem, das du lösen möchtest? Ja, ich finde, es sind zu viele. Es sind auch zu viele, das Problem bei ... Wenn das Loch ein bisschen grösser wäre ... Stimmt, ja. Also ich sag nur, auch Richtung Ernährung und so. Ja, macht das Loch ein bisschen grösser. Wenn wir das Loch ein bisschen grösser machen. Toblerone, man geht mit gutem Beispiel voran und hat jetzt die Lücken zwischen den, also die Negativteilchen der Toblerone. Okay, abgenickt, ja. Ey, solange nichts kommt, mach ich einfach weiter, okay? Also die Negativteilchen der Toblerone vergrössert, so dass weniger Toblerone in einer grossen, handelsüblichen Toblerone packen müssen. Aha, clever ist. Aber passen die jetzt perfekt ineinander? Nein, die haben vorher perfekt ineinander gepasst, oder nicht? Ah, scheiße. Ich dachte, die passen perfekt, ich dachte, dass der Gag, dass man dann so Zähne hat, dass man so dann wie so ein Gebiss hat, wenn man zwei davon hat. Das kann der Gag gewesen sein, ich weiss. So hat es mal angefangen als Gag, aber irgendwie sehr schubelte, ist auch ganz geil. Sehr ernst, ein sehr schlechter Gag. Zu oft um die Ecke gedacht. Nee, genau, und deswegen dachte ich mir, dass man so langsam vielleicht die Donut-Holes ein bisschen grösser macht, um Diabetes und der Überflussgesellschaft vorzubeugen. Ist richtig, oder man packt die Donuts so ineinander, dass man den Nächsten erst essen darf, wenn der Erste gegessen wird. Verstehst du, dass du in so einem Donutladen, du hast eine ganz lange Donutkette und erst wenn der erste Donut aufgegessen ist, kann man überhaupt mit dem Nächsten. Geht so ein Törchen hoch fürs Zweite. Ja, und der Donutladen ist ganz hoch und da hängt so eine Kette runter von Donuts und man darf immer nur den Nächsten essen. Wie so ein Escape? Verstehst du? So dass immer einer unten dran hängt, der den Donut isst und erst wenn der fertig ist, kommt der nächste. Ich bin raus. Ich finde das ist eine sehr gute Idee, achtet mal auf die Startups demnächst. Hast du eine Startup-Idee? Einiges, vielleicht so eine Art wie Twitter, nur dass es... Mit noch mehr Zeichen. Ja, ja, ja, wo man ein Zeichen twittern darf. Aber nur ein Zeichen, überlegst du dir gut. Oder so ein Zeichen mit so einem Button … Ich habe mich gefragt, als diese Diskussion war mit den 280 Zeichen, einfach eine Konkurrenzplattform zu launchen, die wieder nur 140 hat, um mal zu gucken, was so passiert. So ein paar … es reichen ja so 20 Leute, die dann … Da bist du dann nur alleine und postest dann, ha, ha, ha. Aber ich fände es gut, tut da mit so einem Ich-habe-keine-Mine-oder-zu-Button. Einfach so ein Kein-Like, sondern so ein ... Einfach so dieses Geräusch verbildlich, so ein ... Und so ein Hä? Ja, ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen hart ausgedrückt, aber ja. Einfach so ein Neutralitätsbutton, dass du einfach so einen Button hast, der einfach so, ja gibt aber auch einige Gegenargumente dazu und man hätte es vielleicht ein bisschen klarer ausdrücken können, aber ich gebe dir mal den, ja. Gewissen Augen in die Ecke. Ja, oder so ein aufs Handgeleck gucken, so ein auf die Uhr gucken Emoji, einfach so ein Gott, alles klar, notiert. Aber mir auch nicht, aber apropos, letztes Jahr Facebook abgestürzt, riesiges Problem. Letztes Jahr? Nee, dieses Jahr. Ach so, aber ist schon länger her. Ist ein paar Tage her, glaub ich. Ist so, ach so. Bei mir ist es nicht, bei mir ging's. Doch, doch, doch, bei mir ist es abgestürzt und habe mich natürlich sofort an das Social Network erinnert, wo das ein heißes Thema war. We don't crash. Ja genau, we don't crash und dann haben die extra 900 Dollar bezahlt. Ich habe den Film nur noch grob in Erinnerung. Aber Facebook ist abgestürzt und ich dachte, alle haben gesagt, Facebook ist abgestürzt. Ich gehe auf Facebook und merke, na, wer ist doch noch da, kann ich doch noch verwenden, ist doch kein Problem. Und dann ist natürlich passiert, was passieren musste. Genau in dem Moment habe ich ein altes Bild gefunden von einem Schulfreund und mir. Lustiges Bild, lustiges Bild, denkt man, ach warum nicht einfach mal sein, dafür ist Facebook ja da, alte Schulfreunde anzuschreiben, denen man seitdem nichts mehr zu tun hat, auch mit kruder politischer Meinung mittlerweile. Und sie einfach denken, ach komm, und ich wusste, es gibt ja so Leute, die haben ganz speziellen Humor, die haben so genau ein Humor, wenn du so dieses Humorspektrum vorstellst, die haben genau ein pixel dicken Humor und du weisst, das ist genau der Humor. Aber alle, die hier sitzen, haben es ja auch. Wir haben ja alle so und Weihnachten, wenn man das der Familie erzählen will, den Witz nacherzählen will und bei der Hälfte merkt, ah. Ne, es funktioniert noch. Also bin ich ein bisschen verrannt. Und es gibt einfach Leute, von denen kann man den Humor nicht einschätzen, wo man einfach was sagt und dann kommt nichts zurück und dann irgendwie bindet man sich die Schuhe und die lagen sich kaputt. Und man denkt sich, gut, okay, so geht der Abend auch rum. Aber kleiner Einblick in mein Datingleben. Und deswegen, jetzt habe ich mir einen Faden vor. Nein, genau, ein Pixel und dann dachte ich mir, das ist genau sein Humor.
Dieses Bild ist genau sein Humor, weil es war unscharf. Und das liebt er.
Er liebt unscharfe Bilder. Und ich muss sagen, wer bin ich denn, seinen Sinn für Humor zu kritisieren? Wenn er das lustig findet, dann fällt er so sich. Und es ist ja auch lustig. Wir alle lieben ab und zu ein schönes unscharfes Foto. Oder? Ja, also, wir alle lieben unscharfes Foto. Also Wir rekapitulieren kurz die Ereignisse. Facebook war down. Und dann die Geschichte, die du gerade erzählt hast, ist dann passiert. Ich habe mal ein altes, ich habe alte Bilder durchgeguckt, habe ein altes Foto gesehen von ihm und noch ein paar andere Leute, und es war unscharf und er hat ein lustiges Gesicht gezogen, das noch lustiger war, weil es unscharf war. Und ich dachte, das ist genau sein Humor. Also was mache ich, öffne Facebook, suche diese Person, seit sieben Jahren keinen Kontakt, mal bei der Abi-Feier irgendwie gegenseitig über den Fuss gelaufen, jetzt wieder getroffen, und ich schreibe ihm, haha, habe ich gerade gefunden, schicke die Nachricht ab, wildes Bild hochladen, leider ein Fehler im Upload. Aber scheiße, Facebook ist ja offiziell down, das geht ja gerade gar nicht. Die Nachricht wurde aber gesendet. Und dann hast du diesen schrecklichen Moment, zwischen die das Bild einleitende Textnachricht wurde geschickt, das Bild aber noch nicht. Das ist ein häufiges Problem, ja, da kommen schon auch so Fragezeichen, wo man denkt, so far-timing. Und du bist so in diesen 30 Sekunden Schweissausbruch Schwebe, Limbo, wo du in so einem Humorvakuum gefangen bist, wo du nicht weisst, was passiert. Und ich konnte es nicht hochladen. Ich konnte es einfach nicht hochladen. Und plötzlich kommt natürlich Scene. Man denkt, boah, was denkt der jetzt von mir? Ich versuche mit allen Mitteln dieses Bild hochzuladen, es funktioniert nicht, es funktioniert gar nicht. Was waren die Mittel, die du versucht hast? Nenn mir 20 Mittel, die du versucht hast. Ich habe, und ich bin nicht stolz drauf, ich habe das Bild gemacht, ich konnte es nicht hochladen, dann habe ich einen Screenshot gemacht von dem Bild. Dann habe ich den versucht, hochzuladen. Dann wollte ich das hochladen. Dann habe ich wütend bei Facebook angerufen und gesagt, Leute, Leute, Leute, we don't speak English, guys, guys, guys, das ist ein wordlike.
Das ist not uploading. Und ich dachte mir, vielleicht ist das so ein Hack mit dem Bildschirmfoto, keine Ahnung, das wäre irgendwas, was ich als Drehbuchautor in so einen Film reinschreiben würde.
We have the picture here, we can't enhance it closer up, but we can't screen capture it. Und dann geht's so. Und als Zuschauer denkt man sich, hm. Man hat dann diesen Button. Aber man ist nur in eine emotionale Love Story investiert. Richtig. Und man hier nicht ist, leider. Ja, ja, ja. Auf jeden Fall, es hat nicht funktioniert, es hochzuladen, und seitdem haben wir keinen Kontakt mehr. Seitdem hat sich nichts mehr getan, und seit immer wird, ist unsere Konversation, hey, kannst du mich mit zum Abi-Ball nehmen? Nee, leider nicht. Sieben Jahre Pause und dann, haha, habe ich gerade gefunden. Noch mal sieben Jahre Pause und dann tut mir leid, wegen deinem Auto ein Fall oder so was. Ich weiss nicht, wie es weitergeht, ich will es nicht, ich will nicht. Ich meine nur, nur die abstände sind gross und das war es einfach das war es einfach ich bin auch nicht jemand der wirklich gut darin ist kontakte zu pflegen wir sind auch wirklich die sitzen die sind die leute im publikumsbereich wissen als ich mal irgendwann nach nach köln gezogen bin es ist schon schwierig dann dann mit dem ganzen Freundeskreis zuhause noch weiterhin Kontakt zu halten.
Ja, man ist doch auch froh, dass man endlich weggezogen ist für den Vollidioten.
Ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, und man ist auch wahnsinnig traurig. Und dann hat man halt, und dann hat man das Problem, dass man irgendwann in diese Situation kommt, dass man anfangen muss zu schreiben, wenn wir wieder Geburtstage sind, und man merkt, dass die Konversation nur aus Geburtstagsgrüssen besteht und es ist so entlarvend und dann sieht man es irgendwann zu Weihnachten wieder und dann kommen Sätze wie, aber du meldest dich gar nicht mehr und man sagt, klar melde ich mich noch. Hier, ich habe den Screenshot ausgedruckt, lustigerweise wo man... Vor Weihnachten, vor Weihnachten, alles Gürze, Geburtstag, alles Gürze, Geburtstag. Es war noch krasser, weil man in der alten alten Welt so, da kam man damit durch, da kommt man mit Ausreden wie, ja, ich habe mich doch gemeldet durch, weil niemand kann es beweisen. Und dann kam diese Person mit den Statistiken von WhatsApp an und hat gesagt, wo drauf stand, dass sie 97% aller Konversationen angefangen hat, die wir jemals geführt haben. Und es war einfach so eine, es war so eine Ein-Diener-Vier-Seite, fuck you, du bist ein mieser Freund. Alter! Wo man auch sagt, es ist so richtig. Sollte man jetzt das speichern oder sollte man nicht einfach sagen? Ich bin gegen Datenschutz, nehmt was ihr wollt, okay, vielleicht hätte ich mich ein bisschen informieren sollen, aber das ist die einzige Form von Datenschutz, die mich interessiert, ist Sachen, die ich schreibe, die gegen mich verwendet werden können. Alter, wirklich eine WhatsApp-Statistik. Die WhatsApp-Statistik, 97% der Konversationen hat sie angeleiert. Da standen auch ganz viele komische Sachen drin, welche Smileys man benutzt. Man ist auf dieser Seite nicht stolz. 400 Mal verlogenes Lachen? Du fandest es gar nicht lustig? Du hast Hahahaha geschrieben und gar nicht gelacht? Ja, also nicht wohl der das, ja. Verlogenes Lachen finde ich keinen schlechten Emoji zum Einreichen. Das sollte ich vielleicht machen. Stimmt, so Lachen mit so Schweissperlen auf der Stirn, so, ha-ha-ha-ha-ha, ich will nicht, dass unsere Freundschaft abbricht, ha-ha-ha-ha. Das ist doch schon mal ein guter Mimor. Ja, ist gut. Ja, genau. Einer, der sagt, ich lache auch, aber ich habe auch Angst auf der Stirnn. Das stimmt, ist gut. Ich lache so kurz. Sowas in der Richtung. Das finde ich gut. Finde ich auch gut. Wie ist es schlecht. Schreibst du viel bei WhatsApp? Ganz, ganz wenig. Ich schreibe wahnsinnig wenig über solche Messaging-Nachrichten. Es funktioniert nicht. Es kommt immer falsch rüber, ich benutze keine Emojis, alle verstehen es falsch. Und am Ende bin ich zu Sachen eingeladen, wo ich gar nicht hin will. Und dann muss ich mir mal ausreden, überlegen, nicht hinzugehen. Das ist schrecklich. Sag einfach, du hast es nicht gelesen. Wenn ich Facebook-Einladung bekomme, sage ich immer, habe ich nicht ein Date. Wann kam die? Hä? Ciao. Ja? Du meinst zum Beispiel wie damals, als ich dich zum Bowling eingeladen habe? Nein, das war, die habe ich mir nicht übersehen. Bowling? Wirklich? Bowling. Okay, weil ich habe dich im Büro gesehen, wie du auf dein Handy geschaut hast, als ich dir die Nachricht geschrieben habe. So, ne, da kam ein SMS an von einer anderen Bowling-Einladen. Okay, weil, ach so, deswegen warst du auch bei der Bowling-Ally aber zwei Spuren nebenan. Zwei Spuren nebenan. Hast du getan, als würdest du mich nicht kennen und ich habe das... Nee, weil es ist woanders, die Haare neu und die Schuhe, du hast ja auch andere Schuhe beim Bowling an. Ja, Bowlingschuhe. Aber die haben gesagt, hey Stefan, ich bin hier drüben, willst du nicht rüberkommen? Ja, aber wie gesagt, ich habe nicht Schuhen, dachte ich mir, solche Schuhe trägt ja normalerweise nicht. Ja, okay, das ist schlecht. Weil sonst eher so Adidas Sneaker oder so an, aber jetzt trägt er nicht. Bist du gut im Bowling? Hat jemand, bist du gut im Bowling? Ich hoffe Ich würde mich, glaube ich, ärgern, wenn ich gut im Bowlen wäre, weil es ein komplett verschwendetes Talent wäre, wo ich mir sage, okay, gut im Bowlen, dafür bin ich schlecht im Bett, danke schön, vielen Dank, cool, danke. Das ist der Deal, den ich gemacht habe, ich kann bowlen. Das finde ich so schlecht, mit dem Ende des Lebens kommst du an so eine Himmelspforte und du kannst dir deinen Deal eingeben. Ist das eigentlich schon ein bisschen zu spät? Ach so. Außer man kann im Himmel viel bowlen vielleicht, ich weiss nicht genau. Das ist der Donner. Gab es eine Religion, die den Donner damit erklärt hat, dass die Götter bowlen? Das müssen wir auch machen! Das klingt spaßig! Die Götter ziehen um gerade. Wo wollen die hin? Unangebeldete WG-Feier über uns. Gab es eigentlich, also ich kann mir das nicht vorstellen, so antike Götterwelt, wenn es mehrere Götter gab, hatte man da einen Lieblingsgott? Hat man dann zu einem Gott gebetet oder war das dann eher so, Leute, wer gerade da ist, ich weiß, ihr seid wahrscheinlich nicht mal voll besetzt, zwei sind wohl gerade weg irgendwie, keine Ahnung was Zeus macht, wegen meiner Beförderung nächste Woche, ich wollte mal gucken, wäre da eine Gewischen. Mit einem Arm und einem sagen, ich habe damit gar nichts zu tun. Der Trottelstelle. Dann landest du bei so einer Callcenter-Göttin, die er erst mal annimmt.
Ja, das stimmt.
Die erste Mal annimmt.
Die Gebetsgöttin.
Ja, die die Gruppenarbeit macht, die dann einfach so, okay, ich kümmere mich heute mal um die Gebete, aber …
Sie sind bei Athenia gelandet, hallo.
Ja, guten Tag, wir würden gern die Asyra ausrotten, komplettes Volk …
Alles klar, reichst du sofort weiterhin zum Asyra-Austen-Scott. Okay, läuft gut, glaub ich, läuft gut. Nö, ist so nicht so, ist so. Hallo, guten Tag, folgendes, ich hätte eine, bitte, bitte, ich zahl für dich gerne die Asyra ausrotten. Alles klar, bis wann wo du das gemacht hast? Dienstag, glaub ich, Dienstag ist in Ordnung. Dienstag, passt 12 Uhr? Ja, 12 Uhr passt. Alles klar, beschäftigen wir, ciao. Ja, haben Sie noch aufgelegt? Ich hab aufgelegt, alles klar, gut, okay, danke Uhr passt. Alles da, alles da. Gut, hau, hau. Ja, haben Sie noch aufgeregt? Ich habe aufgeregt. Alles da gut, okay, danke. Du musst erst Abend sein. Sorry, Entschuldigung. Aber es hat funktioniert. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, ich habe, ja, ja, ja. Ich sehe gar nichts da drüben. Es gibt auch nichts zu sehen, Freunde, sind wir ganz ehrlich. Das stimmt. Ihr könnt euch das umsonst aber als Podcast anhören, das muss man auch noch sagen. Und tatsächlich war es ja so, dass diese Götterleute sehr gläubig waren und die haben dann vor einer Schlacht, haben die ein Lamm geopfert. Und je nachdem, wie das Lamm ausblutet, geht dann die Schlacht aus. Also wenn es dann nach links blutet, dann oh schade, wir verlieren. Wenn es nach rechts blutet, dann gewinnen wir.
Aber ist das so, wie wenn man abends vor einer Klausur so ein Papierklaut in der Hand hatte und den Mülleimer getroffen hat und man sagt, wenn wir jetzt treffen, ist es eine Eins? Es ist ein bisschen so, aber der Historiker, der das Buch geschrieben hat, hat dann gesagt, ja, es war dann auch Usus, also zum Beispiel man sagt, blutet nach links, ist Schlacht verloren und man opfert halt dieses Lamm und es blutet nach links. Und man sagt dann so, lass es noch ein zweites zur Sicherheit opfern.
Und dann kommt das zweite und dann rechts, okay, rechts, die Götter haben gesprochen, los geht's, ey, das ist eigentlich egal, aber es war eine geile Zeit, glaube ich, einfach, wo du einfach, die ganze Zeit Lammfleisch. Das stimmt, sollen wir das jetzt essen oder? Ach Scheisse. Deswegen gab es da so viele Krähen. Früher gab es viel mehr Krähen, viel mehr Krähen, ganze Wälder voller Krähen. Du gehst in den Wald und sagst, oh Leute, hör mal auf, jetzt zu Krähen hier, das ist so da. Aber wenig Möwen, ne? Tatsächlich sehr wenige Möwen. Tauben? Tauben mittelmässig, tauben mittelmässig, wahnsinnig wenige Möwen muss man tatsächlich sagen. Taubenshirt, what the f- okay, wir haben Taubenshirt in der ersten Reihe. Alles klar, Security! Ganz kurz, es gab tatsächlich ... Leider war Taubenshirt für unser Code-Wort, unser Safe-Wort. Wo hätten wir ahnen sollen, dass du mit einem Taubenshirt ankommst? Es kam gleich so Wasserspritzen vor dem Europa-Eimer. Show-Up. Es gab aber einen Zeitpunkt in der Geschichte, da gab es nur noch zwei Möwen. Und die haben dann wieder alles von vorne angefangen. Zehn Millionen zu zwei. Das ist doch Inzest dann. Das habe ich auch nicht verstanden. Bei dieser ganzen Archenoa-Geschichte. Wie soll das denn funktionieren? So, sagen wir mal Büffel, Frau und Büffel, Mann, kriegen ein Kind. Da steht ja jetzt ein Büffel, dann kriegen die noch ein Kind, einen weiblichen Büffel.
Okay.
Wenn jetzt im Idealfall gäbe es jetzt einen fremden genetischen Stamm. Oder Onor. Ich meine nur, in der Bibel steht, er wurde mit Fruchtbarkeit gesegnet. Büffel, Fruchtbarkeit? Unsererlicherweise.
Sag mal, du unser Sohn, der sieht gar nicht aus wie ein Büffel, habe ich so. Der hat so diese Koteletten irgendwie, so ähnlich wie Noah, jetzt will ich sagen, aber irgendwie, ich meine, keine Ahnung, ist dir das nicht aufgefallen? Naja, wenn du das jetzt ein bisschen sagst, schon ein bisschen weniger. Ich meine, du hast ihn auf die Welt gebracht, also ich meine, wir wissen, dass du die Mutter bist, du hast ihn auf die Welt gebracht und so, danke nochmal, cool. Klar, klar. Ich hätte es auch gemacht, aber geht nicht, aber danke an dir. Nee, geht nicht, klar, das ist schon klar, die Aufgabenbeteilung ist ja ganz klar. Okay, aber kann es nicht sein, dass, bist du sicher, dass ich der Vater bin? Ja, also, klar, gewisse Ehrlichkeiten sind ja immer irgendwie, ich meine, er rückt ja auch für Zeit mit Noah und, weil er hat jetzt auch so ein kleines Schiff gebaut und das liegt gar nicht in unserer Familie. Hast du nicht noch andere Sachen zu tun? Du betreibst schon wieder so viele Gedanken, machst du dir schon wieder? Ehrlich, als Büffel habe ich recht wenig zu tun. Ich habe meinen Bachelor gemacht, ich stehe hier. Aber geh doch mal nochmal, wie du es letzte Woche gemacht hast, an den Bug des Schiffes oder so. Plattritte doch mal die Beine. Da sind dieinguine, Mann, die Nerven. Ja, die Dreckspinguine, Drecksidechsen, aber das ist doch scheiße egal. Ich hätte nicht an dir zweifeln sollen. Okay, alles klar? Sind wir cool? Ja, also, wann kommst du denn wieder ungefähr? Guck mal, wenn die Sonnenuhr so ein Stück weitergeht. Wenn die Sonnenuhr so ein Stück? Ja, so einen guten... Letztes Mal kam es so, da war schon. Sorry, aber dann, wenn wir uns bewegen, ist es okay. Das ist problematisch, wenn sich das Schiff dreht, aber gut. Alles klar. Anderes Thema. Aber kannst du ja mal mit Noah drüber sprechen. Oh, hallo. Aber ich seh den eh gleich. Oh, hi Noah. Oh, hi Noah. Oh, schöner Bademantel. Das ist ein Zufall, hey. Okay. Gut, dann lasse ich euch beide mal allein. Ja, genau, einfach das kurz. Macht's gut, tschüss. Ja, gut. Meinst du, die haben wirklich gewartet? Die mussten sich ja fortpflanzen, aber haben die schon auf der Arche Noah dann angefangen? Ja gut, ich sag mal so, da ist ja auch, es verging wie viel Zeit? Lange, vierzig Tage, vierzig Nächte ich. Wie viel Zeit verging? Oder war das der Film? Keine Ahnung. Du weißt nichts ausser Becher, das ist Fachwissen der Angeil. Ich lese immer die Bibel, werden im Hintergrund Filme laufen, deswegen vermische ich das immer so ein bisschen. Wie viele morgen denn? 40 morgen, 40, ja 40 Tage, 40 Nächte, 40 morgen, 40 Abende, aber wir können es auch abkürzeln und einfach sagen 40 Tage. Mein Gott, weisst du wie teuer Pergament ist? Hallo, ich muss das hier alles aufschreiben. Also ganz kurz, wie lange war die da auf der ... Ich glaube, vierzig Tage, vierzig Nächte. Glaube ich schon. Ich glaube schon. Ich weiß nicht. Vielleicht. Und da hast du dann bestimmt so als Büffelweibchen so, nee, wir warten mal, wo wir ankommen erst mal. Also wir müssen jetzt nicht, also klar, wir sind zusammengeleitet eine Weile, aber lass uns mal gucken, wo wir ankommen, was da noch für Leute so sind. So neue... Stimmt, da gab es bestimmt auch so ein Pärchen, die nicht miteinander was anfangen wollten. Ja. Und dann die anderen versuchen sie immer so zu... Ah, ich hab meine Tage. Ich hab 40 Tage lang meine Tage. 40 Morgen und 40 ich verstanden. Du musst das nicht immer … und alle anderen versuchen sie so zu verkuppeln, einfach so, komm, sie ist doch ganz nett. Ich glaube, es ist doch so Pärchenabend eigentlich, immer so sehr offensichtlich. Ich glaube, irgendwie so die Geparden haben immer so zum Dia-Abend eingeladen und dann, ach Gott, ja für die perfekte Beziehung und ihr habt schon drei Kinder, toll!
Weisst du was ich mir überlegt habe? Gute Einnahmequelle für einen Podcast und zwar, wir machen ... Was? Das ist eine gute Einnahme. Das ist eine geile Idee. Vielleicht komme ich da noch mal drauf zurück. Ich dachte mir sowas wie, viele Menschen haben Beziehungen ... Willkommen zurück, kurz zum Erklärung. Wir hatten gerade das Thema Noah und dann haben wir, also niemand hat Noah gespielt, ich war jemand, ja, wenig Interesse, naja. Ich dachte mir, es gibt, wir kriegen ganz viele Nachrichten und vielen Dank dafür von so Leuten, die immer schreiben so, ah, ich höre mit meinem Freund immer das Podcast-UFO, ah, ich höre mit meiner Freundin immer das Podcast-UFO. Alle sind vergeben, mein Gott. Ah, ich höre alleine immer das Podcast-UFO und so, ah, letztens wollten wir zusammen einschlafen und dann haben wir das Podcast-UFO gehört und haben so gelacht und dann sind wir lachend eingeschlafen und dann sind wir lachend eingeschlafen und dann sind wir, schön, dass ihr so glücklich seid. Und wir schlafen bei mir ein. Das freut mich so für euch. Ja. Deswegen Idee, Idee, Idee. Das ist der Deal, den wir gemacht haben an der Himmelspforte, so vor wie jetzt zu Florentin und Stefan durden. Wir haben gesagt, kein Sexualleben, dafür die Fähigkeit, Leuten ein gutes Sexualleben zu ermöglichen. Aber es gibt ja immer so Themen. Also, Florentin hat gerade Noah gespielt. Mein Gott. Ah, sein Nachbar erklärt sind. Echt, der ist im Kurs. Okay, geht das kurz nochmal raus. Es gibt ja immer so Themen in Beziehungen, die man ungern anspricht. Und wo man dann immer so, ah, der eine hat die Meinung, die andere hat den Meinung, und dann weiss man immer nicht so... Das Thema Podcastwechsel ansprechen. Ja, das auch, oder so, wer hat Recht. und deswegen dachte ich mir als Feature, Leute zahlen uns Geld, damit wir die Meinung von denen übernehmen, damit die in der Beziehung Argumente haben. Dass wenn die sich immer so, irgend so ein Streitthema und dann einfach so, ey Stefan, kannst du mal sagen, vielleicht, keine Ahnung, dass du vielleicht 2000 Euro für den Urlaub ein bisschen zu viel findest?
Und dann wir so völlig natürlich im Gespräch so, ja also ich würde ja niemals Urlaub für 2000 Euro. Bezahlt das Wort. Genau, Werbung, ja. Und dann können die zu Hause immer so, siehst du, da hatten wir doch letztens erst gerade drüber geredet. Und immer so ein Disclaimer. Aber das wäre eigentlich perfekt wie so ein Pärchen-Beratungs-Podcast. Genau. Nicht Beratung, einseitig beraten. Dreimal die Woche mit Tina aus der Buchhaltung zu treffen, finde ich ein bisschen viel. Ja, ich finde, deine Antworten sind länger als ihre Fragen auf WhatsApp. Was ist da los? Zwei Grinze-Smilies sagen, wir wollen miteinander schlafen. Das blaue Herz ist auch ein Herz. Ja, so einfach geht das nicht, mein Lieber. Da sollte ich meine Rangliste her. Nee, da muss was getan werden. Aber ich finde, zwei blaue Herzen sind ein rotes Herz, oder? Nee, nee, zwei grüne Herzen. Grüne ist mehr als blau. Grün ist Eifersucht. Das heißt, ich liebe Eifersucht, heißt das grüne Herz. Es ist sehr verwir ist sehr verwirrend, es ist emotional ganz schwierig. Aber ab jetzt bieten wir das an, schickt uns eure Nachricht für 250 Euro und wir vertreten eure Meinung im Podcast. Ja, genau. Und da muss immer so ein Disclaimer davor. Nichts, was wir sagen, ist unsere Privatmeinung, wir sind bezahlten Parteiverbenspots. Ja. Ja, verdiene ich schlecht.
Wählt, wen ihr wollt.
Aber wählt.
Okay.
Das ist nett. Hab uns so einen Applaus. Einfach mal reingestreut.
Bitte niemanden umbringen.
Wuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuhuuhuhuuhuhuuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuhuh Bitte niemanden umbringen. Bitte? Bitte. Klatschen. Ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert. Ich habe noch nicht herausgefunden, wie das funktioniert. Nicht jede Katze will gestreichelt werden, manche haben sich auch nur verlaufen. Ja. Ja, wenn wir es alle vergessen haben, kann einer von euch dann mal nach vorne laufen zur Bühne und so tun, als würde er uns angreifen? Nein, nein, nein, nein. Einfach nur um es zu probieren. Nein, das machen wir nicht, er hat ja nur einen Ninja-Stern in dem Gesicht. Im Gesicht? Oder in der Hand. Wenn ihr das Gesicht anwerfen, dann weiß ich, wenn wir es alle vergessen haben, so würden wir im Flow sehen, wir lachen, haha, und dann kommt nach vorn und tut mal so, als er bei uns angreifen würde. Ich glaube, das ist eine ganz, ganz schlechte Idee. Ja, ist vielleicht eine schlechte Idee. Weil wir haben natürlich auch Undercover-Security im Publikum. Mit so einer Peitsche. Zum grossen Kescher, die dann die Leute einfangen können, wenn jemand läuft. Kescher sollten generell so ein geniales Konzept so selten verwendet. Selten verwendet? Warum überlassen wir das den Anglern? Die Angler können nix!
Wie bei Pokémon, da hat immer diese eine Art Mensch, alle so ein Kescher. Cool, das fand ich so ein,
es war so ein bisschen so ein USP, aber dann wiederum haben alle diese Art diese Kescher,
aber man sagt, du bist nicht so speziell. Bist du dir sicher, dass es nicht Catcher heisst? Weil Cacher, was ist ein Cacher für ein Wort? Das war es von uns, das war das Podcast-Sufo. Dankeschön! Ich meine einfach nur, es gibt ja die, wir haben ja Polizisten auf Pferden. Wir haben Polizisten auf Pferden. Die haben wir ja. Wäre es denn jetzt so undenkbar, dass die einfach einen langen Kescher in den Namen haben? Weil die haben ja nichts, die haben ja nicht mal eine Lanze oder ein Lasso oder sowas. Da kann man denen nicht einfach so oder einen Sipp haben die einfach jemanden im Kescher? Geht das nicht? Ist nichts für Sie. Es sieht ein bisschen so aus wie, ich wollte meiner Freundin den Podcast zeigen. Oder, nee, nee, nee, ich glaube, ich glaube, sie wollte einfach einen teuren Urlaub. Und jetzt weiter. Wir machen so lange weiter, bis jedes Pärchen gegangen ist. Seid glücklich woanders! Und sie geht wütend vorweg und er läuft an der Bühne vorbei. Er ist zufrieden. Alles richtig gemacht. Das System funktioniert, es sind 250 Euro, die uns durch die Lappen gegangen sind, Stefan T. Da können wir zweimal unsere DNA testen lassen dafür, jede Woche. Und immer gucken, hat sich was geändert. Und immer gucken, es hat sich was geändert. Deine DNA hat sich verändert? Es kam ne Mail, dass sich was verändert hat. Nee, ich glaube, es kam ne Mail, dass sie jetzt andere Möglichkeiten haben, das auszuwerten. Und ich bin jetzt 0,1 % weniger Pole, weiß ich nicht. Aber sei ehrlich, deine Redaktion war schon so ein bisschen yes! Nichts gegen Polen, aber was hast du denn dazu bekommen stattdessen? Spanisch. Oh, yes! Und es gab so einen Punkt in der Woche, wo ich dachte, arriba abajo, wo ich kurz sagte, Amma Amigos, die nächste Runde geht auf mich. Und dann kam die Mail und dann war die Bestätigung da. Und du schreibst zurück so, das ist der Cento. Das dachte ich mir schon ein bisschen. Erzähl mir was Neues, Amigos, Adios, Muyenfuego. Keine Ahnung. Nur 0,1 %, ich bin vielleicht nicht fliesslich dadurch. Das stimmt. Das ist schwierig. Soll ich das auch machen, DNA-Test? Ich weiss es nicht. Nein, es ist dann, ja, es ist dann, es ist vor allem, glaube ich, in Deutschland nicht so richtig interessant, weil die meisten sind halt, wahrscheinlich sind die meisten von uns ein bisschen osteuropäisch, ein bisschen nordeuropäisch, ein bisschen deutsch. Und das war's. Das ist sehr uninteressant bei den meisten von uns. In Amerika ist es halt ein bisschen spannender, weil niemand daherkommt. Es muss nicht alles ein Gag sein, wir können auch mal echte, wahre wahre Fakten sein. Aber dieser fragende Blick nach ... Hat sonst noch jemand eine Frage? Also gibt es sonst noch Dinge, die wir klären können. Ich fühle mich mit so einem Ted Talk auch. Oh, oh shit, ich habe noch was vergessen. Was denn? Wir müssen leider eine nicht ganz so beliebte Rubrik bemühen, nämlich das Podcast Ufo, die Entschuldigung. Okay, alle zusammen! Sorry, wir würden uns nicht bei dem Tauben. Wir haben es verdient. Gut. Wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa-wa- Das ist richtig scheisse gebaut. Es tut mir richtig leid. Und zwar haben wir eine sehr blütende Nachricht bekommen von Christina.
Und äh, es tut mir leid, es tut mir leid. Und zwar, es geht um das Thema und manchmal reißt man so ein Thema auf und man weiss noch nicht, dass man die letzte ... Streit geklärt, alles gut. Sehr gut, sehr schön, da ist das herrlich. Vor allem, wenn das Gespräch wirklich war, der Podcast ist gläubelig für mich, okay, wir gehen und draußen, ja was sind die Alternativen, beste Geister waren, beste Freundin, das war, so Mundschul ist schon weg, so Mundschul ist abgebrochen nach einer Stunde, dann gibt's noch gemischte Sack, die sind ähnlich, keine Ahnung und die sagen okay, dann gehen sie wieder rein.
Ja, manchmal gibt's Themen, wo man sich nicht darüber im Klaren ist, dass diese Themen maßgeblich seinen Alltag beherrschen werden und das Thema, wir hatten ja schon einige Themen durchgenommen im Podcast-UFO und anscheinend das heiße Thema momentan ist das Thema Erkältungsbad. Und ja, ich habe darüber berichtet, dass ich ein Erkältungsbad genommen habe und ich habe mich darüber lustig gemacht über die Warnhinweise auf der Erkältungsbad-Packung, wo nämlich stand, nehmen Sie maximal zwei Kappen, ich habe drei Kappen genommen, ihr könnt mir gar nichts. An der Stelle grosses Sorry und unser ganzes Mitgefühl gilt den Familien von Pascal, dem kleinen Leo und der kleinen Marie, die, weil sie die Folgersufe gehört haben, sich drehen. Der Klasse 4c des Ludwig-Wittgenstein-Gymnasiums. Genau, und der Gruppe Marienkäfer aus dem Kinauspiz Neuwied. Sorry an der Stelle, für drei Wochen im Erkältungsbad waren zu viel. Das war vorher nicht vorzuse, aber … Es tut uns leid. Ja, es tut uns leid. Sorry … Stellvertretend hat uns geschrieben die liebe Christina, die nämlich massiv auf die Gefahren eines Erkältungsbad hinweisen wollte. Erkältungsbad anscheinend ist nicht … Es ist kein Kinderspiel. Es ist kein Kinderspiel. Aber das habe ich auch oft gesagt in diesem Spruch schon, Erkältungsbad ist kein Ponyhof.
Ich dachte, ich bin unbesiegbar, aber dann kommt Christina und Christina schreibt folgendes, pass auf. Ich höre gerade eure Podcast-Ufo-Folge 162 und ihr redet über die Gefahr von Erkältungsbädern, beziehungsweise darüber, dass ihr glaubt, es geht davon keine Gefahr aus, ausser zu viel Entspannung. Das war ein kleiner Gäste. Erste Punkt. Die Klasse 4c ist an Entspannung gestorben. Das tut uns leid, aber manchmal ist langsam an Entspannung gestorben. Finde das, was dich liebt, ne, finde das, was du liebst, egal. Und ich kann euch sagen, die Warnhinweise stehen da tatsächlich nicht grundlos oder aus Placebo-Effektgründen drauf. Ich hatte vor ein paar Jahren mein erstes und letztes Erkältungsbad erlebt. Hohohoho, what? Christina, unsere Gedanken sind bei dir.
Es tut mir leid.
Hier ist Christinas Mutter, die seit dem Facebook-Account aufrechterhält.
Ja. Und jedes Bild. Bitte spenden. Neue Pflanzen ins Profil. Ist das eigentlich die neuen Grabstätten? Sind Facebook-Profile von verstorbenen oder werden die gesperrt? Oder kann man dann irgendwie ein neues Blumenbild oder so, ab und zu die Lampe, eine neue Lampe.
Ich weiß es nicht. Es ist, Christina, es ist noch nicht allzu lange her. Gut. Okay, mein erstes und letztes Erkältungsbad-Erlebnis. Mir wurde nach ein paar Minuten in der Wanne schwindelig und wahnsinnig heiß. Gut, ich habe eine Idee, wie du das Problem hättest besser angehen können. Und ich war nass. What the fuck? Und überall war Schaum und es hat geheilt, als ich gerufen hab, weil ich im Bart war. Und meine Haare waren plötzlich so labberig. Ja, und meine Haut schmuddelig. Okay, sie schreibt aber, um uns den Wind aus den Segeln zu nehmen. Krumpelig. Wie nennt man das, wenn die Haut... Schrumpelig. Oh, okay, ja, da kam sie eine Meinung. Sorry, die können nicht alle durcheinander um. Da kam sie plötzlich eine Meinung. Was, ganz kurz, ich habe immer nicht verstanden. Schrumpelig, sorry. Das hätte ich jetzt, ich hätte nicht schlafen können. Gut. Sie wusste aber auch nicht, hat man gesehen in der ersten Reihe. Ja, ja, den Blick auf den Boden sehe ich schon. Inselbegabung. Also, sie nimmt jetzt aber den Wind aus den Segeln und sie schreibt, mir wurde wahnsinnig heiß. Nein, das lag nicht am zu heißen Wasser. Gut. So dass ich das Gefühl bekam, dass ich sofort raus muss. Ich bin dann nur mit Handtuch auf den Balkon.
Und jetzt wird es eine Fanfiction.
Und dann kam Florentin.
Und dann kam Noah.
Und er trug ebenfalls nur einen Bademantel.
Er öffnete seine Baderobe und darunter war sein...
Gott hat mich mit Fruchtbarkeit gesegnet. Kann jeder sagen, Achtung, und sie schreibt, ich bin dann nur mit Handtuch auf den Balkonen in die Minusgrade gelaufen, was meinem Kreislauf nicht gerade Was ist gerade? Kalt, kalte Temperaturen. Was meinem Kreislauf nicht gerade gut getan hat. Aus dem Nichts habe ich dann noch strömendes Nasenbluten bekommen. What? Wie lange war sie drin? Schreibt sie nicht. Schreibt sie nicht. Aber das ist der interessante Part. Dem Nichts habe ich Strömnis, als ich, weil das ist ja noch nicht genug Drama, dann noch angefangen habe zu hyperventilieren, hat meine Mutter den Arzt angerufen und um Hilfe gefragt. Und er hat gesagt, und er hat gesagt, lassen Sie mich raten, Erkältungsbad. Ja, da gibt es eine Stiftung für die Hinterbliebenen, mehr kann man nicht machen.
Das Ding, na na, Überdosis Erkältungsband. Kleiner Tipp, weniger Erkältungsband. Aber ich finde es auch gut, deine Tochter verblutet und du fragst den Arzt um Hilfe. Entschuldigung, eine Frage, kurz. Ich will wirklich nicht stören. Am Ende lag ich also in einer Blutlache, nackt und in einer Tüte atmend auf dem Küchenboden. Also das war Christinas Bericht vom Erkältungspartner. Okay. Aber leider... Aber leider Gottes fehlt die wichtigste Information, wie lange war sie und wie viel hat sie genommen.
Aber ich finde, so kann es nicht weitergehen. Ich fordere ab jetzt abschreckende Bilder, Aufpackungen von Erkältungsbädern, wie Christina nur mit einem Handtuch bedenkt in einer riesigen Blutlache liegt und währenddessen die Mutter nebenan die Hüfte fragt. Eine Frage ganz kurz, wann haben sie offen, was sind die Öffnungszeiten, wenn die Tochter stirbt? Aber das finde ich sehr gut, so auf jedem Badzusatz, immer so eine schrumpelige Haut oder so, oder Babys, die Angst haben, weil es zu heiß ist oder zu kalt. Oder jemand, der so fast ausrutscht auf dem Boden.
Aber auch ein paar erholte Menschen, weil es ist nicht alles schlecht.
Wie so ein Quartett, für jeden ist was dabei.
Ja, für jeden ist was dabei.
Ja, das finde ich gut.
Bei Raucherbilden ist auch für jeden was dabei.
Vor allem, welches Baby ist auf diesem Raucherbild und irgendwann wird es ein erwachsener Mensch sein.
Ja.
Und dann irgendwann zeigen die Eltern so Kinderfotos und plötzlich ist da so eine ausgeschnittene Zigarettenpackung dabei und die sagen, Moment, was war das denn? Ach nee, nee, nee, das war nur, ihr habt was gemacht, ihr habt Geld dafür genommen, dass ich ein abschreckendes Beispiel bin? Ja, ich weiss nicht, ich arbeite jetzt seit zwei Jahren Vollzeit als Model, aber irgendwie sehr einseitige Anfragen irgendwie.
Also ich habe jetzt eine Krebswarnung, eine Aidswarnung, zwei Verkehrswarnungen, drei, Achtung, Bücher können die Haut schneiden, keine Ahnung was das war. Also irgendwie, ich habe so ein Gesicht, das Leute einfach abschreckt, ich weiss nicht. Ich finde es auch gut, wenn irgendein Kumpel von direl von dir und der erzählt von mir auf diesen Schildern ist, auf der Autobahn, einer schreibt, fünf sterben und dann wird sich so ein Freund von dir abgebildet und der hätte nicht erzählt, dass er diesen Modelauftrag bekommen hat und du fährst vorbei und denkst, what, Martin? Ich denke mir oft, diese Bilder sind wahnsinnig ablenkend.
Ja, wie oft habe ich gelesen, einer stirbt, zwei schreiben, ne Moment, zwei sterben, Auffahrunfall. Vier schreiben, drei Komma acht sterben, zwei schauen zu, also was? Aber auf dem Foto sind sechs Menschen, das heißt, mehr haben überlebt. So eine Formel, ich habe heute versucht, ein Foto von so einem Bild zu machen, habe es nicht geschafft. Ich bin extra langsam gefahren. Ja, du bist extra Vollbremsung auf der Autobahn. Nein, also meine Idee war, es kam so ein Schild näher und dann fand ich es lustig, wenn wir bei Instagram raushauen, wir sind jetzt auch bei Instagram übrigens. Okay, Mark Zuckerberg ist in der zweiten Reihe, sehr gut. Ach nee, doch, den gehört Instagram, das war ein Gezin! Da hat alles in der Regel. Und da kam so ein Bild, da kam so ein Bild, auch schreibt mir eine SMS, zwei Leute sterben. Und ich fand das nicht so schlecht, denn da ist unser, ich fand es ganz lustig, wenn das unser Bild ist, was wir dann mit Roadtrip ins Internet schicken. Und dann hat Flo den aber ewig gebraucht, um Instagram zu öffnen, weil er ist nicht so versiert, muss man sagen. Dein Handy ist zu krass einfach. Dann bin ich extra massiv langsam gefahren auf der Autobahn und hinter mir sind wirklich, das war gefährlicher, glaube ich, als nebenbei SMS zu schreiben. Stimmt, ich glaube auch, die Leute, die dieses Bild aufgestellt haben, da sind locker drei Leute gestorben.
Einfach so, weil es war so ein Hang, so ein Grashang, und der geht halt straight in die Autobahn.
Also wirklich, wenn du da stehst, abrutscht, tot, sofort.
Ich glaube, okay, wir haben jetzt drei Leute verloren.
Beim Aufstellen dieser Schilder sind fünf Menschen gestorben.
Irgendwie kommt die Balance noch nicht so ganz rein.
Ich glaube, es ist extrem gefährlich, diese Dinge aufzustellen.
Deswegen Helden, die das tun.
Ich will die nicht mehr ablenken.
Ja, weiß nicht.
Ja, vor allem, wenn du ja am Steuer gerade schreibst, dann liest du ja die Sachen nicht.
Ja, also das ist ja, eigentlich bräuchtest du so ein Schild, schau auf die Strasse, du Depp, und nicht auf die Schilder. Weil ich mein, du sprichst ja genau die Leute an, die ... Schau auf die scheisse Strasse, du Vollidiot. Ja, du musst aufmerksam sein, um die Bilder zu sehen, aber die sind ja für Aufmerksamkeit, also es gibt überhaupt keinen Sinn. Eigentlich bräuchtest du eher so auf den Handys oder dass die, dass alle drei Minuten schreibt so, schau auf die Trasse, auf die Trasse. Ich bin gefahren und war relativ spät dran und musste dann, ab nebenbei, das haben wir damals auch immer genommen, als wir damals abnehmen wollten beide, haben wir diese Fertignahrung getrunken. Wo man, und die gibt's Jule, kauft Jule. Ja, ich hab das aber genommen, weil es gut schmeckt und nicht, weil ich abnehmen wollte, gell? Naja, du wolltest auch ein paar Kilos loswerden. Ist ganz gut, um mal so eine Mahlzeit zu skippen. Und die gibt's jetzt auch in Fertigform, so Flaschenform. Und dann bin ich tatsächlich neu, weil ich abends keine Zeit hatte zu essen, habe ich mir so ein Ding gekauft,
habe das dann während der Fahrt, wollte ich es noch schnell wegtrinken, also auch essen, also eine Mahlzeit am Steuer zu mir nehmen, wo ich dachte, ist es so clever, ich habe es dann trotzdem machen müssen aufgrund der Zeit. Problematisch war dann nur, dass ich, nebenbei habe ich eine Playlist angemacht und es war eine Classic Playlist und irgendwann war dann, es war halt leider, Ich weiss nicht genau, was war eigentlich so ein Jubiläumsorchesterspiel, wo danach halt bestimmt 50 % dieses Tracks waren Applaus und es war halt das Ende dieses Orchesters. So, dann ist Folgendes passiert, ich war kurz am Ziel, das heisst, ich musste mich aufs Navi konzentrieren, musste viel lenken usw. Problematisch war dann, weil von dieser Juggelflasche ist der Deckel mir in den Fussraum des Beifahrers gefallen. Jetzt hatte ich also diesen Drink in der Hand, musste mit der einen Hand lenken und dann wurde der Track von tolle Klassikmusik zu Applaus. Und dann bin ich einfach auf der Autobahn mit Applaus rundherum gefahren und dachte, das ist absurd. Aber auf der anderen Seite, und es war halt nicht so ein Applaus, der immer leiser wurde, sondern dann kam man offensichtlich noch über die Darsteller auf die Bühne und es gab so Piks, es gab so Uuuuuh. Und dann gab es auch so Momente, wo ich dann um die Kurve gebogen bin mit dem Jewelsaft in der Hand und dem Lenkrad und es war schon eine Leistung auf eine Art. Und dann bin ich rechts abgebogen, richtig abgebogen und die Navifrau sagt, ja gut, die nächste Straße links und der piekt. Und ich dachte mir so, yeah! Und irgendwann war es von unangenehm, wo es in Richtung, ja, es ist schon cool, Auto fahren zu können, es ist schon eine Leistung.
Und dann wurde ich geblitzt. Dann wurde ich geblitzt, problematisch, aber es gibt halt wirklich dieses lachende Bild von mir mit einer Juelflasche und einem, ja, ich bin schon uner Typ. Dankeschön! Und dann voll in Blitzereien, aber gut, das fand ich nicht so schlecht.
Ich dachte mir vor allem, irgendwann haben ja Polizisten aufgehört, wirkliche Blitze am Strassenrand aufzustellen und dann die Scheibe runter machen zu lassen und dann sagen, sie wissen, warum ich sie angehalten habe. Das gibt es ja nicht mehr, neulich gibt es ja nur noch die Kästen, ich wurde ewig schon nicht mehr angehalten, aber wie cool es gewesen wäre, wenn ich mit donnerndem Applaus und so einer Flasche Fertigdrink noch trotzdem noch zu schnell gefahren bin und er
sagt, Sie wissen, warum ich sie anhalte und ich sage, ja, ja, ja, das wäre cool gewesen, leider gab es das nicht.
Aber es ist auch ein guter Effekt, glaube ich, wenn du da mit einer roten Ampel neben jemandem stehst und bei ihm einfach so coole Hip-Hop-Musik und bei dir einfach, wuuu, sehr gut, bravo, bravissimo und du so, oh Gott, die Leute, die braver rufen, aber das hatten wir schon mal. Das ist echt ein anderes Thema für ein sehr spezielles Publikum und ihr seid da alle ein bisschen zu dumm dafür. Ne, man ruft nicht. Ich finde es schlecht, Dinge reinzurufen. Ich bin nicht mehr so ein Woo-Typ, also wenn mir was gefallen hat, würde ich danach nicht Woo-Rufen beim Platschen. Ja, ich weiss nicht, aber ich finde, es ist erstaunlich, wie, also ich bin immer noch bei dem Punkt, dass es jetzt fertig Huel gibt. Ich meine, Huel, das ist dieses Pulver, das man mit Wasser mischt und dann schüttelt. Es geht quasi nicht mehr einfacher. Du kannst drei Euro mehr bezahlen, das ist schon gemischt. Es geht nicht mehr einfacher, aber die Leute, ja, wir kriegen lauter Nachrichten von Leuten, die das Pulver essen oder die nur Wasser trinken oder die erstes Pulver essen und dann trinken. Leute, äh, okay, haut das Zeug fertig. Wir kriegen Nachrichten von Leuten, die zu wenig Müll erzeugen und deswegen, ich dachte, wir jetzt wieder ein bisschen besser. Die baden da drin und die einfach sagen, scheiße, dann machen wir es einfach fertig. Ich meine, das ist wie wenn du so eine Capri-Sonne verkaufen würdest, wo der Strohalm schon drinsteckt. Oder einfach sagst du, es klappt nur bei 50 Prozent der Leute, wir verkaufen die jetzt mit dem Strohalm drin. Es funktioniert nicht anders. Das finde ich ja ganz gut. Heute haben wir sehr unhandliche Trinkgefässe, Flaschen, okay. Und jetzt habe ich gesehen, es gibt wohl diese neue Art Verpackung, und zwar ist es einfach nur so eine Blase Wasser. Und diese Blase kann man trinken. Aus Glas, meinst du? Nee. Nee, nee, nee, nee. Da hast du mich jetzt falsch verstanden. Nee, was meinst du? Das hat so eine Haut. Ach, und dann kann man die so essen, ne? Ja, trinken, essen, da sind dann die Grenzen, sind dann verschwimmen. Aber du kannst einfach so ein Stück Blase einfach ... Ja. Und dann bist du nicht mehr durstig. Aber worin hast du die dann? Also sind die dann los in deinem Rucksack und dann holst du dir raus und snackst sie so weg? Für mich auch, Verpackung ist ja nichts Schlechtes. Also, hat praktische Gründe. Hat jetzt keinen Applaus bekommen, von daher bin ich nicht der Meinung. Aus Umweltgründen, unser links-grün-versifftes Publikum hat halt Probleme. Aber, ooooooooh, ooooooh, ooooooh, ooooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, ooooh, o Ja, auch mal eine Quelle findest? Stefan. Gut. Da ist du Stefan Spritzig, steht dann ha ha ha. Nee, Stefan Karat, Stefan Karat, naturell. Stefan Medium, Stefan Classic, das funktioniert alles nicht. Naja? Na, ich weiss nicht. Was ist eine Quelle? Also wirklich, also ist es ... Sind Quelle ... Quelle ist doch einfach der Ursprung eines Flusses. Ja, aber Sekunde, hey, hey, hey, hey. Aber Sekunde, das heisst, du läufst durch die Alpen und dann siehst du so einen Feldspalt, wo Wasser rausspritzt und dann sagst du dir so, ah, da kommt das Wasser hin. Quelle, Stefan. Stefan Klassik. Stefan Medium. Super nervig, Wander-Trips mit mir sind ... Mit einem Hauch Zitrone, ja. Finde ich so schlecht. Habe ich nie verstanden. Zitrone? Nee, nee habe ich nie verstanden. Ich bin immer noch fasziniert von diesem Mondwasser. Das ist so genial, es gibt Mondwasser, Mondwasser, das wird nur bei Vollmond abgezapft. Ist also irgendein Esoterik-Scheiss. Aber kann man da mal den Verbraucherschutz draufjagen, dass die wirklich kontrollieren, ob die wirklich bei Vollmond das abfüllen? Auch diese Erkältungsparten-Nummer, das wird auch nicht so richtig los. Naja. Wie ist man dann gesund und so, muss man sich testen lassen, bevor man das Erkältungsbaden nennen kann?
Nichts gegen Christina, aber ich meine, warum kriegst du die Nasenbluten, das war ja nicht mal in der Nacht. Vielleicht, schreib mir mal zurück, gerade mal, vielleicht hast du was anderes.
Das ist ein Screenshot, leider.
Okay.
Ich mach alles mit Screenshot.
Aber schreib mir mal zurück, vielleicht hast du andere Probleme, also vielleicht hast du andere Krankheiten.
Stimmt.
Gar nicht böse gemeint, gar nicht oh oh oh oh.
Eher so Service. Also vielleicht hast du andere Probleme, also vielleicht hast du andere Krankheiten. Stimmt. Gar nicht böse gemeint, gar nicht ohhohoho.
Eher so Service.
Stimmt, es haben bestimmt schon viele Leute Sachen verklagt, weil sie kurz danach einen Herzinfarkt bekommen haben. Ja, vielleicht.
Aber es hat ja gar nichts damit zu tun. Ich habe ein Duplo gegessen, da hatte ich einen Herzinfarkt.
Ja, sie wiegen 600 Kilogramm.
Fetty Mac, Fett, Fett, du wie wieg 600 Kilo. Sind Sie wirklich Arzt?
Ja, bin ich.
Aber ich habe etwas extrem dummes gemacht. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es ein Problem ist. Aber ich dachte mir, komm, mach das einfach mal. Meine Lampe war kaputt.
Und zwar nicht irgendeine Lampe, sondern meine Flurlampe. also meine die Nummer eins wichtige Lampe in meinem, wenn man sagt, die top drei Lampen bei mir in der Wohnung. Ich verstehe. Es ist Nachtlicht auf jeden Fall, aber auch diese Lampe, weil die ist schon wichtig, wenn du reinkommst, sonst siehst du halt gar nichts. Und die war kaputt, das war ein Problem und dann habe ich mir neue bestellt und war jetzt irgendwie zu faul, Ich dachte mir, das kriegt man schon hinten alleine, so eine Lampe anzubringen.
So, dann habe ich das abgeschraubt und dann war das so ein bisschen so 24-mäßig, kamen dann halt drei Farben raus.
Und ich dachte mir, gut, warum kein Stecker so, warum nicht einfach Stecker in Stecker, war dann relativ einfach.
Das Gekringelte war Erdung und so weiter und blau in blau und Schwarz in Rot und Schwarz und die anderen Farben halt in die anderen Farben. Aber welchen hast du durchgeschnitten? Keinen durchgeschnitten. Okay. Keinen durchgeschnitten. Und dann dachte ich mir schon, okay, wahrscheinlich mache ich trotzdem was falsch und kurz, kleiner Spoiler, ja, ich habe was falsch gemacht, aber ich dachte mir, wenn ich was falsch mache, dann das wahrscheinlich und die Wohnung fliegt in die Luft, wenn ich gleich die Sicherung wieder reinmache. Und dann ging das aber, was ich nicht bedacht habe, war, ich weiß bis heute nicht genau, woran es liegt, ich wusste auch nicht, dass das ein Problem sein kann, aber tatsächlich mache ich die Lampe an und es war wie zwei Sonnen in meinem Flur, die war gleißend hell. Das habe ich noch nie in meinem Leben, stand ich, das ist kein Scherz in einem Raum, der so hell war. Meine Wände sind weiss im Flur und die haben Schatten geworfen. Du konntest Dinge vor die Wand stellen und die weisse Wand hat einen Schatten geworfen. Es war weird, es war so eine sechsstrahlige LED-Lampe und ich dachte mir, vorher war es halogen und ich wollte es halt zu LED machen. Ich glaube, das hat man in ganz Köln gesehen. Wir dachten, es ist ein Gewitter, aber einfach... Das kann es nicht sein. Es war wie schöne Bescherung, ein Chevy Chase-Film. Einfach und es war seltsam hell und ich wusste nicht, wie das Problem lösen sollte, deswegen habe ich es erstmal hingenommen. Was soll ich jetzt machen, soll ich einen Widerstand dazwischen machen, auf der anderen Seite sind es LED, sind die immer so hell, sind LED immer so hell, keine Ahnung. Naja, vielleicht warst du davor auch einfach nur sehr dunkles Licht gewohnt. Vielleicht war davor alles dunkel und das immer als normale Lichter. Ich war auch ein bisschen stolz, weil ich dachte, ja, anscheinend habe ich die sehr gut angebracht, und anscheinend war es auch eine gute Idee, von Halogen wegzukommen ins offensichtlich produktivere, effizientere LED, was einfach ballert. Aber ich finde es eine schöne Vorstellung, in einem Haus zu wohnen, wo man konstant die Hand vor seine Augen halten muss. Das war wirklich schlimm. Also ja, hier hinten ist der Schrank, genau, Sie wollen den Tischtennisch Schläger kaufen, ja, immer. Dann habe ich das Problem schon vergessen und dann am nächsten Morgen kam der Schornsteinfeger zu Besuch.
Ich dachte mir, das Problem werde ich lösen, bis irgendwer zu Besuch kommt, kein Stress.
Dann kam aber am nächsten Tag der Schornsteinfeger und wir haben beide so ein Thing am Laufen, dass ich immer vergesse, dass der kommt.
Weil ich trebe mich immer morgens in Liste ein, dass ich der Erste bin, damit ich danach vernünftig zur Arbeit gehen kann und ich mich freinehmen muss für den Schornsteinfeger.
Deswegen trebe ich mich immer sehr früh in die Liste ein und ich verpenne immer, dass er kommt, weil ich es immer vergesse. Und er weiss immer schon, wenn ich die Tür aufmache, er hat gewenkt, er hat mich gerade gewenkt. Wow, ich habe noch nie in meinem Leben gehört, dass jemand überhaupt irgendeine Beziehung zu seinem Schornsteinfeger hat. Das ist immer der gleiche Typ. Also als du angefangen hast, mein Schornsteinfeger und ich wirklich nichts, nichts kann dem Satz folgen, nichts. E bin noch nie jemandem Schornsteinfeger begegnen, noch nie. Also so auf der Strasse, läuft vor der Polizei weg oder so, klar, sieht man die manchmal, aber jetzt so, dass ich gesagt habe, ah, Sie sind unser Schornsteinfeger, wirklich nicht, nie. Ich bin immer den gleichen, der kommt jedes Jahr einmal vorbei und jedes Jahr haben wir das Thing am Laufen, er kommt um sieben Uhr morgens, klingelt er bei mir und ich mache Schlaftrunk und im Boxerschloss die Tür auf. Und er kommt rein und sagt, haben Sie mich wieder vergessen? Ich sage, ja, er sagt, okay. Und geht mit Augenrollen an mir vorbei und kennt sich schon aus. Problem, ich habe an diesem Morgen, war ich so müde und habe so sehr vergessen, dass ich einfach stockt und alle Rollladen waren runter, es war Stockfinster in der Wohnung, mache ich die Tür auf und sage, hallo, was? Und er sagt, haben Sie mich wieder vergessen? Ja, okay, ich komme rein, ich mache mal das Licht an. Und er hat dann, ich habe gesagt, ja, sorry, ich will gerade noch schlafen, er hat das Licht angemacht und wirklich beide, wow! Und er hat auch gesagt, was ist hier los? Und es war wirklich, es war Stockfinster im Ganzen, da war es plötzlich gleisend hell in allen Räumen. Und es war wirklich die seltsame Situation, ich habe schon wieder vergessen, wie hell diese Lampe war. Und dachte auch, gestern nach, gestern, das war mit der hellen Lampe, hast du doch nur geträumt, das war doch irgendwie eine weirde Parallelwelt, was war das? Gestern war ich ein bisschen nicht empfindlich. Nein, an dem Morgen war die immer noch gleisend hell.
Dass jemand von seiner eigenen Lampe erschrickt, das ist schon sehr lustig. Aber nicht nur ich, auch der Schornstattweger war massiv erschrocken. Und ich denke mir, der muss doch viel erleben in seinem Leben. Der kommt jeden Tag zu fremden Leuten in die Wohnung und bei mir muss er das Licht selber anmachen, schon weird genug. Er weiss auch, wo das Licht ist, finde ich auch gut. Und er ahnt Schlimmes, macht das Licht an Sonnen. Supernova in meinem Wohnzimmer.
Ich kann mir gut vorstellen, dass jemand sein Licht so hell hat, aber dass du auch erschrocken bist, für dich das anscheinend auch neu war, Lichtsagen.
War schon sehr lustig.
Aber konnte er dir da helfen irgendwie?
Nee, wir sind Schornsteinfeger.
Ja, aber ich dachte jetzt, ja, das ist doch weitestgehend der Bereich.
O, O, ja, wa, ja, ja, ja, okay.
Früher, früher hätten die was an der Helligkeit deines Feuers machen können zum Beispiel.
Ja, das stimmt.
Ja, ist ein bisserl dunkel, oder?
Ein bisserl dunkel.
So haben die gesprochen?
Ich weiss nicht, wie ein Schornsteinfeger spricht.
Weil du einen kennst.
Ich hab noch nie mit einem gesprochen.
Doch, die reden ganz normal, das sind normale Menschen. Haben die so einen Spruch, so gut schorn? Gut schorn. Steini, steini, schorn, schorn, schorn. Nee, er hat keinen Spruch. Aber was macht denn der Schornsteinfeger in deinem Haus? Also warum muss der da rein? Der geht zum Gas, Boiler, Therme, diesem Ding, was manchmal Geräusche macht. Ja. Ge geht er hin, was meine Wohnung warm macht, auf wundersame Weise, und sagt kurz und testet es kurz. Und dann geht er wieder und sagt, ja, passt schon, passt schon, passt schon, und dann geht er wieder und ist meistens ein bisschen angenervt. Ich weiss nicht, erwarten die einen Kaffee oder erwarten die zumindest jemanden, der Hose anhat, ich weiss nicht genau, was ist denn genau, was ist denn die Gepflogenheit, wie man mit einem Schornsteinfeger umgeht.
Das lernt man nicht in der Schule, sowas.
Nee, aber du hast es ja schon gesagt, ein Schornsteinfeger hat schon alles gesehen.
Also der, was der jeden Tag sehen muss.
Ich kann dir sagen, der hat zum ersten Mal eine richtig helle Lampe gesehen.
Das war wirklich auf der Neuliste.
Check.
Krass. Aber gibt es auch moderne Schornsteinfeger oder haben die dieses klassische traditionelle schwarze Schornsteinfeger-Ding an? Der sah ganz normal aus. Der sah ganz normal aus! Ja. Ja. Also die hatten ja manchmal so einen Zylinder und dann diese Schornsteinfeger-Feger. Ja, dieser Morgenstern, ne? Genau. Wow! Das wäre eine geile Waffe für Polizisten, die reiten. Ja! oder so ein Kescher an der Kette. Vergiss mal den scheinen Kescher. Nee, ich bringe es nicht. Ich habe viel gekauft, ich habe Aktien, in Kescher-Aktien gekauft. Ich finde das lustig. Und diese Segway-Polizisten, Segway-Polizisten, wo man auch sagt, ihr braucht ein Gadget, was es cool macht. Ihr habt ein Gadget, was euch uncool macht. Einfach so ein Streitkolben in der Hand. Ein Kaufhaus-Cop. Ja, das finde ich. Alle Polizisten auf Seiko, ich dachte, mein Kaufhaus-Cop braucht. Der Waffel-Cop, glaube ich. Wer klaut Waffeln? Bist du da wirklich, musst du dann wirklich sagen, Entschuldigung, Sie haben jetzt hier die Waffeln genommen, oder muss man die aufhalten? Hast du mal geklaut eigentlich so, aus Versehen oder was? Ne, ne, ich habe auch absichtlich geklaut. Ich habe auch schon aus Versehen geklaut. Und aus Versehen klauen ist fast noch schlimmer, weil du kaufst ein, legst, ich habe dann alles in meinem Rucksack getan, tue alles aus meinem Rucksack aufs Band, tue dann wieder alles in meinen Rucksack und merke aber beim Reintun, oh Kochschinken. Schön Kochschinken im Rucksack behalten, nicht auf die Dinge legt. Und dann ist ja blöd, weil dann habe ich alles reingetan und dann denkst du, soll ich jetzt nochmal sagen, oh sorry, ich habe das aus Versehen geklaut. Dann dachte ich mir, fuck life, gehe ich nach Hause, schön Kochschinken. Jetzt lasse ich mir erstmal ein Tattoo stechen. Und ich sag mal so, noch nie war Kochschinken so lecker wie dieser Kochschinken, den ich geklaut habe. Und ich habe mit einem Kumpel von mir auch eine Flasche Fanta geklaut. Das war so der coole Neujahr an der Schule, fünfte Klasse. Fanta-Sohn, das war früher mein Spitzname. Das stimmt, das ist so der Crossover, wo unsere Geschichten sich einmal überschnitten haben davor. Ansonsten noch nie. Und wir haben die Flasche geklaut und dann haben wir die in so einem kleinen Waldstückchen versteckt, wir hatten den gleichen Weg nach Hause, und haben jeden Tag einen Schluck davon getrunken.
Das war so unsere Trophäe. Das war eine zwei Liter Flasche Fanta und wir waren so gross, das war wirklich...
Wir haben das Verstecken wie so ein Flachmann-Alkohol.
Nee, das war, hallo, wir waren fünftige Klasse, da ist man acht oder so, keine Ahnung, da ist es halt cool.
Und dann tatsächlich, jeden Tag gehen wir dahin, unser kleines Geheimnis, oh, jetzt gehen wir zu unserer Flasche und alle anderen so, ja, ist mir scheissegal. Und wir trinken aus der Flasche, eines Tages kommen wir von der Schule zurück, gehen zu dem Waldstück, der Wald ist gerodet, der Wald ist abgeholzt, weg. Und eine grosse Coca-Cola-Fabrik. Und wir dachten uns, scheiße, sind wir auf der Spur. Aber tatsächlich seitdem nie wieder gesehen. Ich stelle mir immer vor, wie so diese Fanta-Flasche noch dasteht, aber so in der Mitte auseinandergeschnitten ist und noch so offen ist, wo die Kettensäge einmal so durch ist. Aber wir haben danach dieses Stückchen nie wieder betreten. Aber apropos, wie ihr die kriminelle Dinge tun, lustigerweise kam auch mal eine... Wir kriegen immer sehr viele Nachrichten von euch, vielen Dank dafür, und jetzt kam neulich mal eine Nachricht, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das gesehen habt, haut mal eure coolsten Cop-Stories raus. Wann habt ihr mal mit der Polizei zu tun gehabt, wann hat mal jemand, wann kam mal die Cops und haben euch festgenommen oder so und dann hat er so ein paar Cop-Stories von sich erzählt, wo ich ihm kurz, ich hätte kurz, war kurz davor zurückzuschreiben, wir sind die auf der anderen Seite der Cop-Story. Wir sind die, die die Polizei handeln. Ja, wir sind die, die die Leute anzeigen. Haft mal eure geilsten Anzeige-Stories raus. Was ich so lustig fand. Weil er war der Meinung, dass wir diejenigen sind die Cop-Stories. Nee, ich wurde früher mal verprügelt, auf der Nachanzeige gestandet, um die Körperverletzung. Das ist meine Cop-Story. Ich bin einmal ich ein Zusammentreffen mit der Polizei, anscheinend bin ich in der Rasterverhandlung gefallen. Und zwar laufe ich so nach Hause, irgendwie kein Problem, nachts und plötzlich wirklich mit quietschenden Reifen. Mich fasziniert immer, wie du läufst. Locker, lässig. Kein Problem. Mache Musik auf dem Ohr oder gar nichts? Ich hab ... Ohne Musik auf dem Ohr.
Nee, ich mach selber Musik, ich freu mich immer.
Und ich lauf so und plötzlich hinter mir mit quietschenreifen kommt ein Auto zum Stehen.
Ich erschrecke erst mal, zwei Männer steigen aus, kommen auf mich zu, keine Uniform, gar nichts,
aber sagen halt, ja hier, wir sind die Polizei, pass auf, können wir mal in einen Rucksack schauen.
Hätten Sie sich auch ganz kurz, hätten Sie sich auch in eine Uniform anziehen können. Ja. Wenn der erste Sitz ist, wir sind von der Polizei, nicht erschrecken. Und dann haben Sie gesagt, können wir mal deinen Rucksack anschauen. Und es war sehr unangenehm, weil zu der Zeit habe ich sehr viel Tabletop gespielt. Da baut man so kleine Figürchen, so Ritter und Zauberer, malt die an und baut auch so Modelle, also so Landschaften und so. Und da gibt es dann so Flock, womit man so Gras imitiert, so kleine Flocken, so grüne, wie so eine Art ganz feines Styropor, so Styroporkügelchen. Aber halt so Flock, alle wissen, die Insider wissen, was das ist, und davon hatte ich eine Tüte im Rucksack. Oh nein, Modellgras. Und der war anscheinend auf irgendeiner Drogenfahndung. Und es war halt wirklich so Flock für Baumkronen. Und er guckt es halt an und wirklich so, noch nie haben wir den Falscheren gefunden auf einer Drogenfahndung. Aber hat er das direkt gecheckt? Aber ja, vor allem, na ja, ich glaube, er hat sich schon gefreut, dass er so ein Plastiktütchen gefunden hat in meinem Rucksack und dann so, das erzähl ich allen auf dem Revier und so und dann war das so flock. Und dann so Tütchen ruht er raus mit Weisspulver und du sagst, ja das ist der Schnee. Es wird eine Winterlandschaft. Gibt minus eins auf Bewegung. Es wird eine traumhafte Winterlandschaft. Und dann hat er mich so, hat er mich befragt und dann sagt er, wo kommen Sie denn her?
Und ich sagte, ja, ich komme jetzt gerade aus München, bin der S-Bahn aus München gekommen. Was haben Sie in München gemacht? Ich war im Kino. Welchen Film haben Sie angeschaut? Wohl im Privatgespräch dann. Okay, bist du einsam, bist du Freunde? Und ich so, ja, Black Swan. War zu der Zeit 2009. Und er hat gesagt, wie ist der Film gewesen? Und er hat dann wirklich gefragt, weil anscheinend ist das dann so die Idee, dass die dann Alibi überprüfen. Weil die, keine Ahnung, ich gehe davon aus, dass sie irgendwie irgendeinen Drogendealen...
Und wie viele Popcorn-Tüten wird sie diesem Film geben, von Nummer fünf...
Ich glaube, die haben irgendwie irgendeinen Drogendealer verfolgt und dann ist der weggelaufen
oder irgendwie so und dann haben die halt gesagt, Rasterfahndung, alle fetten Typen mit lockigen Haaren, nehmt die fest und dann hat er wirklich gesagt, worum geht's in dem Film? Und dann stehst du da diesem 55-jährigen Mann gegenüber, der halt und dann sagst du ja, es geht um eine Balletttänzerin, die... Also es ist schon mit Dämonen und so. Sie haben sich einen Ballettfilm angeschaut. Ja, aber es ist ein cooler Film und Ballett ist auch cool und ich lasse mich jetzt hier nicht in die Ecke drängen. Und dann hat er wirklich noch gefragt, wer spielt da mit? Ja, Natalie Portman. Und er hat wahrscheinlich noch nie den Namen Natalie Portman gehört. Wenn jeder der Filme guckt, weiß er, wer mitspielt automatisch. Das dachte ich mir auch, deswegen dachte ich, wird das jetzt irgendwie so ein Filmquiz oder was. Aber ganz merkwürdig, du stehst dann plötzlich da und dann sagt er, was kommt in dem Film vor und du denkst dir, ja, wie soll ich jetzt den Plot zusammenfassen? Ja, also diese Ballettänzerin Nina, die kommt an einen sehr strengen Trainer und wo wollen wir jetzt hin, wo geht's hin, wollen sie den Film singen? Feist mal den Soundtrack. Ja, und es war sehr unangenehm und irgendwann meint er dann so, na okay, na dann noch schönen Abend. Und ich so, okay danke, dass Sie mich nicht verhaftet, vielen Dank, was soll jetzt hier passiert. Das war mein einziges Zusammentreffen mit der Polizei, extrem unangenehm, extrem peinlich, aber hat auch Spaß gemacht irgendwie. Also es war schön, ich dachte mir so, wenn ich in eine Rasterfahndung falle, dann bin ich ja schon so eine Art kriminelle Art. Also ich sehe so ähnlich aus. Aber wenn danach irgendwie so eine Zeitung in Ebersberg, da so ein Bild rumgeht, bin einfach du mit so einer Augenklappe und du sagst, man hätte draufkommen können, dass er derjenige ist. Ich bin so ein Schnurrbart, ja das stimmt schon. Und, aber ganz im Gegenteil, tatsächlich eher im englischen Garten wollte mal jemand Drogen von mir kaufen. Der kam zu mir und hat gesagt, ja hey, so was geht? Ich so, ja, passt. Und dann bin ich so, ja hast du was? Und ich so, was meinst du? Hast du was dabei? Ich habe Miniatur, Schnee in meinem Buch. Schnee, keine Ahnung. Erstmal interessiert es sich immer für dich. Ja, und ich halt so, ja, ich komme gerade von der Uni. Und er so, ja, okay. Und da habe ich keine Ahnung, wo es ist. Und welche Vorlesung, was so. Und ich glaube, es ist halt so unangenehm, weil ich glaube, unter Drogenkaufen hat man halt viele Codes und so Begriffe, aber bis man dann wirklich sagt, ich möchte von dir Drogen erwerben gegen Geld und nicht so, ach so, nee, tut mir leid, habe ich nicht, aber danke, danke Mann, geil, fühle mich gut. Aber ich wurde auch mal gefragt in Köln am Ring, ob ich Koks hätte und ob ich wüsste, wo es das gibt. Und dann habe ich einfach ihm dann die Adresse gegeben von dem Ort, wo ich glaube, ich habe kein Wissen darüber, aber wo ich mir vorstellen kann, dass es da Koks gibt. Ja, aber was ist das für eine Adresse? Erstmal fand ich das cool, dass er mich angesprochen hat. Ich habe dann auch versucht, ich kam aus England, ich habe so ein bisschen versucht Smalltalk, dem ging es nicht im Smalltalk, ist mir relativ schnell klar geworden, dem ging es mehr um den Ort, wo es Koks gibt. Und dann dachte ich mir, ja gut, dann frage ich jetzt nicht mehr, wo aus Newcastle herkommt, etc. Gut, und dann hat er gefragt, ja, wo in Köln gibt es denn Koks? Und dann habe ich gesagt, wenn dann so da hinten, Ebertplatz. Und dann hat er das Wort nicht verstanden, und dann hat er mir einen Zettel gegeben, dann habe ich ihm Ebertplatz aufgeschrieben und dann habe ich ihn das hingeschickt. Weil das ist bei dir in der Ecke, lustigerweise. Ebertplatz? Unweit, glaube ich, wo du wohnst. In dem gleichen Viertel. Krass. Aber da dachte ich mir, weil das sieht immer so aus, als ob es das da gibt. Aber ich dachte mir, doch, versuch mal dein Glück. Aber ich dachte mir gerade wirklich, rückblickend, hätte ich dir wahrscheinlich einen Modellbau-Flock verkaufen können. Weil wenn jemand so inkompetent im Drogenkaufen ist, dass er mich anspricht, dann glaube ich, hätte der alles gekauft.
So eine kleine Schranke oder so, was du für einen Modellbau gibst.
Ah, das ist ein Fantasy-Universum, Stefan, die gibt keine Schranke.
Wie?
Aber tatsächlich, das war eine erbärmliche Zeit, aber ich glaube, nie war ich Uncooler.
Ich habe dann auch von McDonald's, ich habe dann auch immer, weil ich wollte mir so eine kleine Hütte bauen,
und dann habe ich immer so von McDonald's diese Umrührstäbchen geklaut aus Holz. Und ich dachte halt so, ja krass, aber du kannst jetzt ja nicht mehr als zehn mitnehmen. Und dann dachte ich mir, jedes Mal, weil ich bei McDonalds war, habe ich so zehn mitgenommen, habe wirklich so mich umgeguckt und so, ja, okay, was, neun Kaffee für euch, okay, alles klar, nehm zehn Umrrissstäbchen und irgendwann nach Monaten, wirklich jeden zweiten Tag bei McDonald's gewesen, 17 Kilo mehr und dann hatte ich genug Stäbchen, um die Hütte zu bauen. Und das war der Grund, du hast sehr viel zugenommen, weil du einfach diese Dinger brauchst. Weil ich ausreden... Und du hast sehr viele Möbel, weil du bei Ikea immer diese kleinen Bleistifte mitnehmen kannst. Ja, das stimmt. Ich habe immer Ausreden gebraucht, um zu McDonald's zu gehen, um mir diese Stäbchen zu holen. Und am Ende habe ich diese Hütte gebaut und ich habe einen grossen Fehler beim Bemalen gemacht und das war alles umsonst weggeschmissen. Fehler beim Bemalen? Ja, ich habe zu dicke Farbe benutzt und dann waren die ganzen Details verwischt. Oh, die Details! Ja, die Details waren weg. Die Details waren weg? Die waren weg. Die kriegst du auch nicht wieder. Das ist wie ein verschwommenes Bild. Wie meine Bachelorarbeit. Die Details, an denen hat es gescheitert. Ja, das stimmt. Das stimmt. Es war eine schöne Zeit. War eine schöne Zeit. Ja, das glaube ich dir, Dude. Ich glaube, dass du eine richtig schöne Zeit hattest mit deinem Modellbaukram. Da gab es ja in München auch so einen Hobbyladen, wo dann da alle waren und alle zusammen Figuren angemalt haben. Da habe ich auch mal Figuren angemalt, aber ich war immer so nervös, weil ich unter Leuten war, dass ich immer Farbe verschüttet habe. Und die Farbe ist sau teuer und nicht dann immer so, oh sorry, sorry, sorry. Super unangenehm. Aber man verschüttet oft Dinge, wenn man nervös ist. Ja. Ich habe vor ein paar Folgen schon mal angetiessen, hier bist du neue Feinden. Als erwachsener Mensch hat man selten neue Freunde und selten neue Feinde. Man hat viele Menschen, mit denen man gut ist und mit der Arbeit versteht man sich gut. Man hat viele mittendrin. Ich glaube, als Kind waren 50% der Leute, die du kanntest, auch deine Freunde. Oder Feinde. Die sind extrem gedacht. Als erwachsener Mensch hast du das nicht mehr. Du kennst zwar mehr Leute, aber ein Grossteil sind völlig irrelevant. Ich mache jetzt Sport, habe ich schon vorhin angekündigt, ich mache es jetzt wirklich mit diesem Elektro-Kram, vergessen wir es, aber es ist, du bist halt 20 Minuten in der Woche, machst du halt Sport, EMS-Training heißt das, und gehst dann zu so einem kleinen Laden, das sieht aus wie so ein kleiner Kiosk, mit so einem Glas, mit einer Glasfront, wo alle reingucken können, die ganze Zeit, wenn die abends daran vorbeigehen, und du stehst da drin und machst halt weirde Übungen in so einem Taucheranzug mit Elektroden auf dir drauf. Mal gucken, was das bringt. Die Idee ist, du bist dann stärker durch diesen Elektroanzug oder was? Oder was ist die Idee? Nee, nee, da wird halt, what the fuck. Also das ist wie dann so ein Cyborg und dann so, oh, 100 Kilo, kein Problem. Nein, nein, nein, das Gegenteil ist der Fall, du bist natürlich schwächer. Du bist noch schwächer. Ja, also ich kann nicht mal die Stange hochheben. Okay. Also die Idee ist, dass die ganze Zeit so ein kleiner Impuls durch deine Muskeln gejagt wird und dann ist es halt besser, wenn du dann Hanteln bewegst oder du machst halt einfach Liegestütze oder einfache Übungen, dann wird es durch den Stromimpuls erschwert und dadurch werden alle Muskelgruppen beansprucht und so weiter. Und dann sagt man das 20 Minuten, irgendwie vier Stunden im Fitnessstudio ersetzen oder sowas. Ist ja auch mal, es ist ja auch egal, jedenfalls kam ich dann da hin und aus irgendeinem Grund, man macht das immer zu zweit und da ist eine eigentlich, eigentlich sehr nette Mitarbeiterin, die das immer macht da mit einem und aus irgendeinem Grund hasst die mich. Ich weißiss nicht genau warum, aber seitdem ich reingekommen bin, hasst sie mich. Und sie denken, ist immer egal, es sind immer andere fremde Menschen, die neben mir diese Übungen machen, die da hinkommen und die werden immer begrüsst und es heisst immer, hey, und wie war dein Tag und was ist eigentlich mit deiner Tochter, die hat doch jetzt wieder von der Klassenfahrt gekommen und so, und bei mir ist immer nur, ah hi, ja hier, dann schmeißt sie mir den Anzug immer hin.
Und es ist wirklich, man hat das ja selten und ich finde es aber immer ein bisschen cool, aber die hasst mich offensichtlich, ist eine ganz grosse Antipathie und ich weiss nicht, woher die kommt. Und dann ist es mir auch passiert, weil ich aus irgendeinem Grund, ich habe wahnsinnig schnell, du durste ich immer bei diesem Sport, weil das so wahnsinnig anstrengend ist Und man muss auch wirklich sagen, dass sie einen wirklich ... Also du willst nicht eine Person, die dich hasst, die deine Trainerin ist bei diesem Sport. Das willst du einfach nicht. Bei den anderen ist sie immer, hey, du machst das richtig gut. Alle kriegen immer High-Fives am Ende von Sitzungen. Kriegen immer High-Fives. Ich habe nicht einen High-Five bekommen bislang. Das ist wirklich gefühlt. Und dann sagt sie immer, mach mal Liegestütze. Ich sage, ich kann keine Liegestütze. Ja, geh auf dir die Knie. Und dann muss sie das auf die Knie machen. Dann sagt sie, die Slipper kümmert dich aus. Ich sag, ich weiss! Und dann dachte ich immer, mach mal Liegestütze, ich kann keine Liegestütze, sie hat die Knie und dann muss sie das auf die Knie machen und dann sagt sie, Silber kümmer dich aus und ich sage, ich weiss. Und dann sagt sie, mach mehr, deswegen bin ich ja hier. Ja und dann kommt so ein Battle und dann sagt sie, jetzt steh auf, ich kann nicht mehr, ich steh auf. Und das ganze geht so und ich weiß noch nicht, ob das Teil des Konzepts ist oder so, ob ich ein Kreuz bei, ich hätte gerne eine dominante Trainerin gemacht habe oder so, jedenfalls behandelt sie mich so und alle anderen immer
wahnsinnig nett und ich weiß nicht genau warum, dann ist auch so ein bisschen dieser Druck und ich stelle mir mein Glas, was man dann bekommt, immer neben die Matte und dann hat sie beim letzten Mal und man hat sie mir den Haar in den Augen gesehen, als sie mich gesehen hat, dann stand ich da in einem lächerlichen Anzug mit lächerlichen Elektronen und dann beuge ich mich runter und genau in dem Moment kriegt man halt diesen Stromschlag und mein ganzes Glas, es war wirklich randvoll, kippt um auf die Matratze und man hat den Blick gesehen. Und dann ist der ganze und dann ist es so langsam geflossen und ich habe schon gesehen, das ist nicht gut, es floss in diesem Stromapparat. Ah, zu dem Rentner, der neben dir trainiert gerade. Und die Frau, so eine schwangere Frau neben mir, stand da so und dachte mir so, fuck, und dann fliechst du das Wasser, fliechst so langsam in diesem Strom. Dann haben wir halt eine Barrikade aus Handtüchern bauen müssen, damit das Wasser, es war furchtbar unangenehm, aber genau so was passiert halt, wenn man so ein Druck ist, so ein Deliver-Druck ist. Aber da sollte es auch keine offenen Gläser geben, ehrlich gesagt. Warum gibt es denn, warum haben wir diesen hoffen Hass geben? Ja, aber hast du vor, da irgendwas zu machen, die mal anzusprechen und sagen, du, lass uns mal einfach auf eine Pizza treffen oder so und mal alles ausreden. Ich verstehe auch nicht genau, weil ich dachte, okay, die sind einfach länger da als ich, die gehen schon zwei Jahre dahin. Nee, die sind seit zwei Wochen dahin, ich bin schon vier Wochen da gewesen oder sowas. Und dann fragt der die auch sowas wie, ja, Lisa, wie geht es denn nach Verletzungen? Und die Trainerin sagt, ja, ist schon wieder ein bisschen besser geworden, ich überkompensiere. Und gehe dann immer so in die Gespräche rein und sagt, ah ja, was hast du denn da genau für eine Verletzung eigentlich? Was aber sehr sarkastisch klingt. Naja, es ist schon ein bisschen problematisch. Scheiße, hast du schon mal einen erfolgreichen Feind zu einem Freund gemacht? Nee. Nee, ich auch nicht. Ich habe nur einen Feind und der ist immer noch mein Feind. Und der wird es wahrscheinlich auch immer bleiben. Ich habe ihn gegoogelt, sieht sehr gut aus. Hat keinen Wikipedia-Eintrag. Gut aussehender junger Mann, kann man nicht sagen. Ach so, er sieht sehr gut aus, ich dachte, das sieht sehr gut aus, dass Reyes gewinnt. Nee, nee, nee nee, nee, nee. Hat ein Wikipedia-Eintrag? Wenn du Wikipedia-Eintrag hast, hast du entweder grandios versagt in deinem Leben oder du hast wirklich was erreicht. Es gibt nichts dazwischen. Ja, oder du bist Sportler. Also nichts gegen Sportler, nichts gegen Sportler, aber jeder einzelne fucking Sportler hat eine Wikipedia-Seite. Bei mir ist es ja oft so, Oskar Pistorius hat sowohl was erreicht, als auch richtig Scheisse gebaut. Das stimmt. Der bräuchte eigentlich zwei Artikel. Ein objektiv besten Wikipedia-Artikel. Der bräuchte zwei Artikel. Ich habe ja oft, wenn mir nichts einfällt und ich irgendwie nach kreativem Input brauche, mache ich ja immer zufällige Seite bei Wikipedia. Und wirklich, Leute, ist es euch nicht bewusst, 90% der Wikipedia sind Namen von Sportlern, meistens ungarisch. Es ist wirklich so viele Konsonanten, holy crap, es ist unglaublich, wahnsinnig sportliches Land, es gibt einfach nur einen sehr motivierten Ungarn, der einfach sämtliche Sportler seines Landes da reinschreibt. Es ist unglaublich, wahnsinnig viel. Ich habe ein Interview gesehen, an das ich keine Erinnerung habe, weil es so ein Durchscrollen war, deswegen freut euch, ob ich die nächsten fünf Minuten, aber es war halt so ein Typ, der Wikipedia-Seiten so viele Seiten korrigiert und so. Ja, genau. Ich weiß darüber gar nichts mehr. Was hat er denn gesagt? Die Doku war 30 Minuten lang bestimmt, so ein Video mit ihm. Ich habe nur das Thumbnail gesehen, der Typ, der für die Hälfte von Wikipedia verantwortlich ist, und sagte mir, ja, mehr will ich gar nicht wissen. Also was sagt ihr, der sagt dann, ja, ich schreibe den ganzen Tag für Wikipedia. Ich weiss es nicht mehr. Und manchmal baue ich auch einfach irgendeinen dummen Scheiss rein. Das kann nicht so spannend gewesen sein. Ich habe keine Erinnerung mehr daran. Naja, gut. Man weiss es nicht. In diesem Sinne. Man weiss es nicht. Manchmal lösche ich einfach Sachen. Meinen Wikipedia-Artikel gibt es übrigens gut. Er hat den Test der Zeit bestanden. Es gibt einige neue Filme. Meine Lösch-Diskussion wurde auch bekriegt. Ja? Ja, und jetzt wird nicht gelöscht. Cool. Das ist doch gut. Sehr gut! Aber es stehen hohe Sachen drin. Stefan Tietze offiziell. Es stehen seltsame Schwerpunkte drin mit Bandzeit und so was. Wenn ich für die Westfälische Zeitung geschrieben habe, das waren zwei Wochen. Ja, das ist das Ding. Das ist das Ding. Ich habe so eine Mini-Matz mal geschrieben für die Götz-Alzmann-Show, war fünf Minuten meiner Zeit und nimmt so viel, bestimmt 20 Prozent meines Wikipedia-Eintrags, hat in den Jahren bei der Götz-Alzmann-Show mitgewirkt. Aber ich lösche das ja nicht, wenn ich denke, klingt cool. Warum soll man das löschen? Man kann sich den Schwerpunkt seines Lebens nicht aussuchen.
Du kannst ein erfülltes Leben leben und am Ende sagen alle, ja, der ist da von der Rutsche gefallen, oder?
Da ist der von Götz Salzmann.
Ja, man kann sich das nicht aussuchen.
Ich weiß nicht, wofür wir am Ende unseres Lebens erinnert werden.
Vielleicht gibt es noch irgendeinen grossen Skandal.
Vielleicht für die Show in Essen.
Vielleicht auch nicht.
Vielleicht fein noch irgendwo.
Okay, grosser Lacher, grosser sarkastischer Lacher. 80% Essen-Show.
Denn leider Gottes müssen wir so langsam die Sachen zusammenpacken. Wir haben nicht so viel mitzubringen,
drei Flaschen jeweils Wasser. Die sind wahnsinnig dünn, da kommt wahnsinnig wenig Wasser draus.
Es wirkt dann immer so, als würde man wahnsinnig durstig sein, wenn man lange trinkt, aber es kommt einfach nur wenig raus.
Vielen Dank. Die sind wahnsinnig dünn, da kommt wahnsinnig wenig Wasser draus. Es wirkt dann immer so, als würde man wahnsinnig durstig sein, wenn man lange trinkt, aber es kommt einfach nur wenig raus. Deswegen mag ich Punica-Flaschen, die haben eine sehr grosse Öffnung. Sorry, ist jetzt so ein bisschen so ein PS-Nachtrag, aber Punica-Flaschen finde ich immer geil, weil du einfach zack, Durst gelöscht in Sekunden. Ist ja auch so bei Werbungen oder so, da darfst du deine Flasche bis zu einem gewissen Winkel ansetzen und alles drüber ist krankhafter Alkoholismus.
Also locker so ein Becks irgendwie so bis hier ist okay oder krankhaft. Darfst du nicht drüber machen. Das ist nämlich die grosse Schwierigkeit bei Becks-Werbung, dass man es nicht so sehr kippt, weil es immer nidier aussieht.
Warum ist niemand in der Ecke, das ist ja eigentlich ein lustiges Easter Egg, in jeder Becks-Werbung einzuplazieren, der es einfach braucht gerade. Du brauchst nicht zu hohen Winkel, um das Bier in den Biertrichter zu gießen. Das muss dann schon gewahrt sein. In der Ecke von der Becks-Werbung einfach so ein Typ. Im kurzen. Der so vier Klopfer in der Hand. Auch ein anderes Getränk, Alter.
Einfach so.
Ich trinke Wasser.
Wegzieht nebenbei.
Oder so als Gegenüberstellung.
Als Gegenüberstellung, ja.
Damit der Backstrinker nicht so negativ auffällt.
Finde ich ganz gut.
Floti, wir müssen langsam packen.
Ja, Stefan, es war fantastisch.
Vielen Dank, dass Sie da waren.
Vielen Dank an Essen.
Wir werden jetzt gleich... Ganz kurz, bevor er applaudiert, da ist gerade jemand gegangen. Ich finde es lustig, wenn wir jetzt ganz kurz einfach beenden, alle rausgehen, er kommt wieder und der Saal ist leer und wir behaupten, dass es diese Show nie gab, okay? Alles klar. Mach so, vielen Dank, wir sind gleich im Anschluss noch am Mördstein, falls ihr uns treffen wollt. Ansonsten... Sag gerne Hallo, begrüßt uns das schöne Barbe. Vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen, Schäfer, Tietze, meine Damen und Herren! Macht's gut, danke schön an euch da oben.
Danke schön, das ist auch so, die Tränen.
Um eine Reihe, vielen Dank, danke schön.